Sorry for the long waiting screen.
So sorry.
Had some issues.
But I think they are now resolved.
Yeah, there's Barry.
She's silent.
I've silenced her.
Today will be a silenced collab.
I'm just kidding.
I should probably get in call with her.
I'm ready too.
I've silenced her.
Call me.
Why haven't you called me?
Where are you?
She's so shocked.
Why is she shocked?
Oh, never mind.
Hello?
Oh.
I'm live, by the way.
I don't know if you are.
I'm live, too.
Oh, okay, okay.
Hi!
Why are you laughing?
No, it's because when we started the collab, you, like,
popped in behind me, but I was covering the screen, so I
didn't notice that you popped in, and when I suddenly moved,
I saw you.
And you scared me.
I'm a ghost, that's what I do.
I know!
Oh, Frank, she's just so good at haunting.
I know, guys.
are you ready to play some freaking oh yeah what's up oh i
was about to ask you like the same thing are you ready to
play some wait actually i am i am curious what what is your
experience with the halo franchise um i know that red versus
blue exists
Okay, I played one Halo song in orchestra.
Okay, I think that's like around the same.
I'm also aware of Red vs.
Blue, but I've never played...
Oh, I've never watched it.
Yeah, me neither, me neither.
Okay, cool.
We're like...
Oh, it's so insane.
This is good.
Yeah.
We're gonna accidentally rage bait so many people.
I know, I already had someone be in the chat being like, I'm
gonna yell at her and tell her to use the classic graphics.
think everybody else should too and i'm like shut up don't
yell at me for nothing why are we yelling i'm how are you
supposed to yell at me about something that i don't even
know exists yeah we we haven't even started yet you guys
yeah all right i'm launching the game hold on okay oh wait
oh frick i didn't i don't i don't think i adjusted the sound
volume this my blast my eardrums my antennae i think it
starts with like a big wow wow oh no no
do this okay i gotta lower i gotta lower okay okay okay
actually maybe maybe we should have tested the co-op before
why would we what that's not no no we're yeah we're we're
freestyling yeah we're freestyling it's fine yeah wiki wiki
wiki it's fine whoa i know this song i think this is iconic
the song it is it is wait no what what i i changed my my i
changed my freaking uh i changed my name but it didn't
update so i'm like what are you i'm gonna be like the rando
oh wait are you done don't laugh what is it what's your
embarrassing random name it's like it's like a classic
adjective noun oh pussy slayer no no is that a red versus
blue reference i don't know probably i think so
Wait, hold on.
I'm trying to...
Jeez.
Okay, how do we...
I mean, we're doing the combat evolved anniversary, I think.
Wait, so if I go to...
Okay.
Wait, where do I go?
If we go to multiplayer...
Yeah.
And then...
We do...
No, no, no.
Maybe not multiplayer.
Wait, hold on.
Isn't that what we're playing?
I think multiplayer is like...
For...
What's it called?
things okay so campaign okay yeah campaign invite i'm
inviting maybe oh yeah i'm reporting mint phantom oh wait
but it was it was it gonna be my um my what's a what's a
microsoft account no i see you through steam oh okay i
didn't get anything though Uh-oh.
Can you invite me?
Can you invite Coro Park?
Wait, we're doing the anniversary one, right?
Yes.
Halo CE anniversary.
I don't even see an invite.
I literally... I updated my freaking thing before stream.
Why am I... Why?
Why am I still this?
Oh, am I invisible?
Oh.
Okay, I'm online now.
Yeah, but I don't see invite anywhere.
Like, it doesn't say...
Wait, is this it?
The game session.
Where's the invite button?
If you press the...
Minto did not download the game.
This was 30 gigs.
What do you mean I didn't download the game?
You have to install every individual game in the collection?
Wait.
No.
Wait, wait, wait.
No, there's no.
No.
But it was 30 gigs!
What?!
This is not the game?!
Oh.
Uh...
Okay, I mean, I did see all of those, I just thought they
were useless.
Okay, um...
No, wait, I...
Wait.
It doesn't say the game.
It says mod tools.
Yeah.
We're not downloading mod tools.
And then everything else is 2, 3, 4.
I mean, I'm downloading mod tools.
tools now just to like wait do i have to download every
single thing to get to play the one game
no no oh wait okay yeah so when you're in the and when
you're in the camp so when you click campaigns and then
click halo ce um and then when you click missions yeah it
says missing content you have to customize your install
you're so right wait what the no no what is that no way
that's not i'm just gonna install both though okay wow it
was so big of a thing i know i was like oh frank okay accept
selection okay i have i have like one thing down installed
How do I have Malo Reach installed, but nothing else?
I guess we gotta play Reach.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, why is Reach...
Oh.
Oh, it's only 8 gigs.
It's fine.
Yeah, but my game isn't capturing.
What the hell?
Uh-oh.
Dude, it's over.
Um...
No.
Desktops capture.
Are you capturing through game capture?
Yeah, I'm through game capture, I think.
What?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What is wrong with my game then?
Hold on.
What's wrong with you?
Well, you can't say that.
I just did.
Mint, I...
I...
What's it called?
I have mental illness, and...
How dare on mental illness month or something.
Yeah, what month...
Guys, what month is it?
It's September.
No, no, I'm...
Surely there's a special...
There's a special thing about September, right?
Is it Mental Health Awareness Month?
I think it is, actually.
It is, actually.
Yeah.
I don't...
It's Mental Ill Berry Bug Month.
It's true.
It's Berry Bug Month.
Oh!
My game is ready to play.
No!
I'm getting mugged.
Wait, then how did you invite me?
I'm so confused.
I invited you on the main title screen.
I don't know.
It allowed me to invite you, but I don't know if you see...
That's weird.
My...
Oh,
there we go.
Wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow.
Dude, okay, I'm almost done.
I'm almost done.
I believe you.
Thank you.
for waiting so patiently what's toggle so we're gonna be oh
okay uh there we go oh oh oh okay invite does that work no i
didn't get anything damn i don't even see an invite that
you're talking about oh whoops it says i'm inviting you
somehow hold on one second player details i'm docking you
invite player to oh invite player okay there we go set as
rival I can set you as my rival that's so mean I set you my
rival someone said it should be the top corner there's
nothing there I don't know I see no thing to invite I guess
I have to play solo no yeah we'll just we'll start the game
at the same time and then next the snowman next oh here we
go um find player but okay i gotta search for your gamer tag
can you please oh no okay so it's coral park 535102 wait
what is it can you type it yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i
got you i don't know why my freaking my freaking thing did
an update first it was like uh I tried to make my Microsoft
account earlier and they were like um you're uh you're being
suspicious right now so we're not gonna let you make it uh
come back in a day and I was like okay what you're being
suspicious I'm being suspicious man coral park
oh wait I guess I have to type it in okay that's fine what
Oral Park.
Okay, Grandma.
I found you!
Oh, invite player.
Let me try inviting you.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Did you get that?
No.
What the heck?
Uh-oh, we're so...
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
It might be finicky.
Hold on.
View shared files.
I'm reviewing your career.
Don't want to view my career.
uh what the hell uh yeah the classic puzzle of starting the
game like does anyone have any someone said just give it
time and i don't know if they're being serious or not what
there's no way we just give it time it should be instant
though toggle five friends no yeah i have that too mint has
to accept invite from in oh maybe you have to start it first
and then and then do it oh maybe maybe okay i'm gonna maybe
it's you're on like the pillar of autumn right and
everything yes yes yes yes yes okay oh some people say wait
some some someone said no you do not no don't start okay
just kidding oh oh you do it from the menu you okay okay you
have to make a party before you start well ain't that
there's swale that's real funny um coral park i'm gonna
invite you again and i'm gonna set you as my rival yes yes
okay and i'm reporting you for bad behavior no no no Dude,
I'm gonna get a VAC fan on my account.
Really suspicious name.
Suspicious activity all around.
Yeah, wait.
Let me restart my game, maybe.
Maybe it's...
Maybe.
Maybe, yeah, I'll restart my game, too.
Okay.
Maybe if we both restart and then...
It'll start working.
It has to.
Right?
if not i guess we'll just uh play halo in our minds on club
penguin or something well i'm i'm pushing i'm pushing and i
shot and i jump and i jump in the car oh i just got more
kills than mint hold on how did you do that no you didn't
oh yeah we could go on roblox halo Whoa!
Don't sound so excited.
No, wait, wait, you gotta give...
Dude, right now, what's really big in Roblox right now is
that there's like obstacle courses and but all the...
When you land on or jump on anything it makes an ASMR noise.
What is an ASMR noise?
Like crackles and like...
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
People are just like running around and crackling and...
Yeah!
keyboard obby dude nice okay i sent you another thing
and okay i did not receive anything
this is so great hold on uh what is the steam button yeah
that's what i was about um maybe from steam um what's my
unread message oh it's from Snuffy.
What'd she say?
Maybe you could try writing Snuffy and see if it works for
her.
It won't let me, like, invite you.
Wait, um... Yeah, what the... Okay, wait, hold on.
Oh, wait, wait, wait.
It says invite to watch.
That's all.
Invite to watch.
Do you want to watch me?
You might have to...
How RP, like, being there beside you.
Okay.
Enable Xbox theme bar?
Game bar.
What?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Halo Master Chief Collection Co-op.
How to.
Okay, quick.
Help us.
Help.
Okay.
Help, help.
Xbox account, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
Play online with a friend who has their own.
You can play, okay.
To play with friends online, you must first add them on a
friend on your Xbox.
Xbox account, but we are already friends, no?
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
On Xbox account?
Yeah.
I don't think so, no?
Like, can you add Coral Park 5-3?
Oh, my God.
Okay, wait.
How do I even... Five-three, five, one.
How do I access my Xbox account?
What the...
So... Yeah, I...
Wait, if I go...
Okay, okay.
Okay.
It also says i can't join you for some reason so i feel like
uh file share no no no no no no no no i'm signing into my
okay windows g send a code i don't feel like doing it oh my
god okay hold on i'm gonna try xbox no i'm gonna try i'm
logging into my microsoft account okay at this very moment
Okay.
I am now online, so I don't know.
Okay, I'm watching some guy's YouTube video.
Hold on.
Uh.
Okay.
He's clicking on...
How do I add friends?
Oh my god, my account is just angry at me.
It's just yelling at me.
Is it screaming?
It's like, your Microsoft 365 family subscription has
expired and your cloud storage is full.
You've used seven gigabytes.
And also, the support for Windows 10 has ended.
Dude.
Dude, what's that guy?
Bob Gates?
No.
Bill Gates.
Bob?
No.
Bill Gates is coming after you.
He's knock.
He's been knocking, like, since January.
Oh, my Xbox profile.
Okay, I'm going to my profile.
You can't view this profile until you sign in.
Okay, sign on.
Okay.
Yeah, this guy just clicks invite and it like...
It works.
It just works.
Like people just join him.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to add you, Coral.
I'm going to add you.
Thank you.
All right.
Let's see.
How do I add people?
Xbox.
I have people wanting to be my friend.
You guys can't be my friend.
What?
Wait, how did they...
Why doesn't...
Why doesn't Coral Park 535120 ever get friend requests like
that?
Coral Park 535102.
Nothing's come up.
Uh-oh.
Wait, people, people.
Nothing!
No!
You don't exist?
You don't exist!
Um...
I think I gotta go talk to Bobby.
Uh...
Xbox profile.
Oh!
Wait, no, because I'm not!
I'm because I changed my name wait no hold on does this when
you click this does this pop up if or anything oh let me try
is it yes oh berry bug add friend add friend I like your
Minecraft thank you wait by sending this friend request your
real name will be shared please what does that
docks yourself from you men Okay, got it.
Except my friend request.
Okay, I'm waiting for, uh...
From... I'm waiting for a notification.
Oh, Maid Mint Phantom wants to be your friend.
Yes, yes, yes!
That's me.
Now I have one friend.
F9 to view.
Okay, invite...
To new party?
Maybe?
No, I think it's trying to get me to, like, talk to you
online.
Okay, hold on.
Oh.
All right, I'm going to do another campaign.
Okay.
Mission.
Oh, I see you!
I see you!
Invite player!
Yes!
Wait, I see it!
I see it!
Yes!
Oh my god, we did it!
We did it!
Oh my god, we did it.
Okay, okay, we did it, guys.
We did it.
Everything is fine.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
What happened to my YouTube?
Oh, hold on.
My chat disappeared.
Wait.
Uh-oh.
Chat, where'd you go?
I-boos.
How dare you?
Believe me.
Okay.
And then we can play the game, baby.
Oh.
Okay, I'm ready.
Turn on scoring, by the way.
You can see who's better at the end of every mission.
No!
They just want to see me suck.
Shut up.
No, no, no.
Everyone knows that you're an apex predator in apex legends
and that you're globally in Counter-Strike and that you're
ascendant in Valorant.
And, you know, I have no idea what half those words mean.
Okay.
What's skulls on mean?
I think those are special things you can find throughout
the...
Oh.
Neat.
Non-scoring or scoring.
Wait, should I have them on?
Oh, they're just challenges.
Oh, they're challenge modes.
Okay.
Start games on Pillar of Autumn.
Pillar of Autumn.
on baby let's go i'm starting the game all right i'm ready i
started wait oh oh there's another start you have to press
start twice so that there's a countdown okay oh do they
expect you to know how to play this game i maybe i think
maybe worst Halo gameplay you guys ever see.
No, it won't be...
Eh.
God, I was scared.
What happened?
Oh my god.
It just said connection lost.
You will disconnect in 15 seconds.
Oh my god.
They don't want us to play this game.
Eh.
Spaceship.
Wait, actually, yeah, I don't know anything about Halo at
all.
Yeah, me neither.
Like, I don't even know what we're doing.
Is this like...
Is this...
All I need to know is...
Did we lose them?
Oh, there's no subtitles.
I think we both know the answer to that.
Wait, what are my subtitles?
No subtitles.
Eh.
Wait, there's actually no subtitles, what the frick?
Yeah.
We made a blind jump.
How did they...
Get here first?
Master Chief without the helmet?
It must be.
Master Chief.
Master- Cheese.
Master Cheese.
No one could have missed the whole we tore in subspace.
They were waiting for us on the far side of the planet.
I want to keep watching.
Oh!
Subtitles!
There you go, Subtitles settings.
Wait, where'd you find it?
Uh, if you press Escape and then press and go to the last
one.
Achievements?
class battle group no accessibility oh i see i see a group
and in about 90 seconds they'll be all over us they i
they're not showing up though oh no no they should never
mind they showed up they showed up oh it's keys everyone no
cheese cheese oh cheese and cortana the k is silent cortana
oh my god i've already begun she was on the the one of the
microsoft uh He is by Crosaugh.
Wow.
Are we going?
I'm...
Wait, so...
I'm assuming one of us plays as a master chief?
Who's the other one then?
Master...
That could be two masters.
Master squeeze.
Are you playing controller or are you playing mouse and
keyboard?
I'm playing mouse and keyboard.
Okay, me too.
You heard the lady.
Move like you got a purpose.
Oh, move like you got a purpose.
Oh, maybe this is the training.
No, they just said this is not a drill.
I think we're in trouble.
No, no, no, no, no.
No.
We are leaving this ship, Latour, and engaging the Covenant
on solid ground.
When we meet the enemy, this is a font choice.
Yeah, it's not really that good for reading.
Sir, yes, sir.
Damn right I am.
Yeah, it's pretty bad.
Attention all personnel.
We are re-engaging the enemy.
External and internal content.
Whoa, whoa.
All you green horns who wanted to see Covenant up close.
This guy's got to be Master Chief.
Everyone in this game, we're all Master Chief.
We are all Spartacus.
Spartacus?
Yeah, it's like they're all Master Chief.
Master Chief is a concept.
Oh, yeah.
Cracking the case in 30 seconds.
Oh, there he is.
There he is.
Wait.
Where me?
We're coming out of a pod.
We're being birthed right now.
He's hot.
Floor the pins in five.
It's him.
John Halo.
John Halos.
God.
Where'd you come from?
Master Chief.
Master Chief, I'm a gang fan, Master Chief!
Oh, me too, me too!
Wait, I have to...
I have to change the FOV.
I mean, I need my fishbowl.
My fishbowl setting.
Can you run in this?
Is there only running?
I think there's only...
I have no weapon.
Yeah.
We gotta use our fists.
Wait, hold on.
Is there a...
Whoa!
Wait, you can press tab and it, like...
It, like, sends you into the...
Oh!
Whoa!
Is this like a proto build?
Like, what is this?
I think that this is like the original release and then you
can do the remaster.
Whoa!
Oh my god, they like completely, look at the guy.
He like turns it to a different person.
This way!
Oh.
Oh, he's done.
Where'd he go?
Oh my god, I need to change my freaking...
I need to adjust all my set.
Oh!
Wait, what happened?
Uh, somebody died.
What?
The guy that was leading us literally just died.
Mint, what did you do?
I didn't do anything.
I don't know.
I didn't see nothing happen, so I feel like...
Mint!
I didn't touch him!
Look, there's blood here.
I wasn't...
I was standing here.
Oh, shoot.
See, it was all you?
It was only you!
What?
All right, let's get through this.
Oh, gosh, the jump is kind of crazy.
Oh, someone died over here too!
Didn't!
He's clipping through the floor!
Ah, he's not clipping.
Oh, he is.
Is there weapons over here?
I think you're game.
What's this way?
Nothing.
Ah!
Oh!
Uh, I think maybe we gotta go this way.
Just kidding.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Just, uh, look out for the fire.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
Ouch.
Oh, oh, oh, no, he's so scared.
He's crying.
Oh, no.
Oh, wait.
Who's attacking you?
Oh, wow, there's space aliens.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, they kind of just threw us into it.
What's going on?
I don't know.
Wait, what do they look like in...
Oh, dang, I missed it.
Oh, my God.
Everybody's dying.
Stay back.
Okay, did they have a gun?
No gun?
What the hell?
We just... We're just not doing any...
Can I get a gun?
Can I get a gun, please?
They're not giving us a gun.
Wait, I...
Oh, F is not flashlight.
It is grenades.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah, it's dark here.
Jesus.
Why do they turn into different people?
They took away your hair, man.
Fight back.
Why are they all bald in the remake, but...
Wait, damn.
I see
Oh, we're getting Four is flashlight Down Yeah, yeah Four
Four is flashlight Thank you guys Thank you Oh, what the
fuck Oh, I got TP'd Cause you were ahead of me Oh, wait,
that's crazy Oh, there's like some real What do they look
like?
Oh, wow They're kind of Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh These guys can
all These guys are also like um just standing here we're not
doing anything man we're useless are we supposed to be
useless maybe the captain needs you on the bridge asap oh
okay okay wait what's over here wait oh sorry i just want to
see if there's anything else oh like any secret who's that
oh wait are you alive are you okay oh my god he's seen
things
He has a stomach ache.
Toggle on this guy between the...
Why is his mouth open?
He has a tummy ache.
I know, they do.
You okay?
Poor guy.
Family guy, death pose.
It seems today.
All you see is violence.
And that's the reason.
Space aliens.
Oh, interesting that they also have guns.
I guess I didn't expect that.
Yeah, you got him.
You got him, buddy.
You got him.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, wait.
I'm actually, I'm stuck.
Oh, we're following this guy.
Things are, like, exploding, and we're just kind of doing
nothing.
Yeah, we're kind of just, like, being useless.
Yeah.
Oh, okay.
Uh...
Captain Cheese?
Oh!
Captain Keys.
What the...
Flash game.
Good to see you, Master Chief.
Things aren't going well.
Cortana did her best, but we never really had a chance.
Oh, that... Hello.
Captain Keys.
She's so quiet.
I know, right?
I had to turn off my audience.
Sleep well?
No thanks to your driving, yes.
Whoa!
Wow, we sound sexy.
They got a little something something going on.
It must have been one of their boarding parties.
I guess an anti-matter charge.
Bam!
Fire control for the main cannon is offline.
Oh my god, the old graphics are really good.
Just in hinge their jaws.
That means you too, Cortana.
Well, you do what?
He's got a pipe.
Can we toggle in the cutscene?
No, we can't.
I'm going to try and land the autumn on it.
With all due respect, sir, this war has enough dead heroes.
I appreciate your concern, Cortana, but it's not up to me.
Protocol is clear.
Destruction or capture of a shipboard AI is absolutely
unacceptable.
When did this game come out?
2001.
Lock in a selection of emergency landing zones.
This looks really good, then.
Yeah, right.
We're knocking on it, but we're appreciating it, guys.
Don't send us hate mail.
Get Cortana off this ship.
Get only hate comments from the Halo community.
They'll learn everything.
Force deployment, weapons research.
Earth.
The autumn will continue evasive.
Wait, sorry.
What about Earth?
I don't think I was paying attention.
Oh, gosh.
Okay.
I suggest letting my subroutines handle the final approach.
Excellent work, Cortana.
Thank you.
Are you ready?
Yank me.
Yank me!
What?
Oh my god.
Cortana, you're so forward.
Okay, so basically Cortana has the location of Earth, so we
don't want them to find out about Earth.
Okay.
Don't get any funny ideas.
Why does he sound like snake-ish?
Yeah, I know.
Whoa, get off the pillar of autumn.
Whoa, imagine having...
Oh, we're good.
I thought we both died.
I thought someone stood up.
Whoa.
I like...
Wait, when I switch back and forth, Are you?
Is it for you too?
Or is it on your own screen?
No, I have my own thing.
Okay, okay.
We need to get going, Chief.
We need to get off the ship before it's completely overrun.
Yeah, I was trying to, like, body block you from coming
back, but I thought I killed you for a second when you fell
off.
Oh, look.
Fight for her.
Do it for her.
Oh, do it for her.
Marine scooters are for squirts.
No scooters on deck.
It's for squirts?
Marines.
Oh no.
Answers to Jonesy.
Oh.
Don't.
Put away.
Whoa.
Oh wow.
Oh no.
In the remake it says cat found.
That says.
Oh wait.
Oh.
Wait where does it say cat found?
Oh cat found.
Wait.
I don't think that's a cat.
Does it respond to Jonesy?
the goose that's pretty fun how do you see my goose wow oh I
kind of like the changes me too I do too yeah that's fine
fist of the unicorn nice alright where are we headed this
way oh oh wait what the hell oh my god go mean go go mean go
there's like little guys already oh shoot go mean go go mean
go go Back you up!
Oh, are you there?
Oh, shoot.
I'm behind you, don't worry.
Who's evil?
Come, go!
Do what you do best.
Oh, yeah, that's true.
I drew.
Oh my god!
I guess the guys were glowing.
Oh, you're evil.
Me?
No, I was shooting at him.
Hey, who shot me?
Oh, no!
This way, this way!
I think they're coming!
Oh!
Oh my god!
Wait, how'd you dodge?
Did you dodge?
I saw a guy, like, roll dodge.
Oh.
Dodge roll.
That's what I meant.
Eh.
Oh, shit.
Ah!
I almost died.
I'm actually almost dead.
Dude, who did that?
I don't know.
Oh, you revived, though.
Nice.
Okay.
Oh, nice.
Maybe we...
There's one way.
over here but maybe we go that way I'm not sure hold on mmm
no okay shields reach the way captain I'm the captain yeah
you're the master chief so are you
why are they screaming like that holy dude maybe we're the
bad guys maybe oh nice Wait, why do you have- you have like
a cooler looking gun than I- oh wait, is this- is this just
this gun?
Oh, no, you have like a different gun.
Wait, oh wait, how'd you get that gun?
How'd you do that?
I don't know.
Hold E to swap?
Oh.
Wait.
Wait, what?
Oh, yeah, that's the one you're holding right now.
Oh, oh, there's different guns.
Oh, you can pick up different guns, I guess.
Oh, I see, I see, I see.
Oh, yeah, you can swap for their guns, but they're dying, so
I think they have weak, pitiful guns.
I don't think we should compare guns like that.
I think all guns are probably, you know, made equal.
I just picked up some plasma grenades, and I think I'm going
to use them.
That's F, right?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Oh.
Oh, this charges.
Holy shit.
Dude, you're a murderer.
So are you?
No, I would never kill anyone.
My mom would never let me do that.
Please, Master Chiefs.
Master Chiefs.
Did something just hit us?
What the hell?
Oh, oh, move it?
Uh, move it.
Is it this way?
I guess we'll just follow.
Yeah, we'll follow them.
Whoa, there he is.
Oh, what's that?
Cavalini.
I'm going to get out of there.
Oh, wait.
Why on your side?
What's happening?
Like, I think we're like- I think the NPC sounds are so
awesome.
I know.
They're so, like, wimpy sounding.
They're like, wap, wap, wap, wap, wap!
Wap, wap!
Don't kill me!
Oh my god.
What are you saying though?
I don't even know.
Oh wait, look, there's stuff here.
There's stuff here.
Wait, where are you?
I need to adjust my volume.
This shit is loud.
Yeah.
You got it?
Wait, wait, Barry.
There's things here.
Right here.
Wait, wait, where are you at?
Where are you at?
Oh, turn around.
Oh, this guy.
We go out and they come in.
Clever bastards.
What is that?
I don't know what.
I picked something up.
Is there anything over here?
I don't know.
Maybe it's ammo?
I think Cortana just told us to go in here.
Okay, okay.
Oh, E to swap.
Picking up their gun.
Oh, there's grenades on the ground.
Pick up that grenade.
Oh, I think I'm full.
I think we're both full.
What is this?
Picked up an overshield.
Oh, me too.
Whoa.
Oh.
Ooh.
I don't feel any different to you.
I think we just have a shield now.
so hopefully wait I feel like coursing I feel like coursing
through my body you do oh I feel like coursing oh shit so
freaking dark I got you
uh oh I have a shield over a shield oh nice oh wait I can't
oh oh no
We're gonna start outlining you guys.
I know, right?
Well, this guy at least has like a shield.
Oh, ouch, ouchy, ouchy.
Get out of here.
You do a really good impression, actually.
Because they sound like minions.
Oh, wait.
I can see it.
There's a health thing there if you need it.
Oh!
Oh, I don't think I need it.
Thank you.
How do you find ammo though?
Maybe you just have to switch guns if you run out.
I guess so, right?
Yeah.
Wait, what do they look like?
Oh, I got teleported.
That was freaky.
Oh, oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, that's what's...
Whoa!
Hey team, what's up?
Yeah, good job team.
Good job team.
Yeah.
Oh, we can- we can- Oh!
Oh!
I feel like we're doing pretty well against them.
I don't know.
Oh my gosh, who's attacking me?
You!
Oh!
Oh, behind us?
Oh.
I got him.
We good?
Oh, shoot.
Never mind.
There's a guy right there.
I guess I didn't expect the...
Oh, my God.
You didn't expect what?
I didn't expect the enemies to actually be like human-like,
I guess.
Or just like use weapons.
There's another pod here if you want another shield thingy.
Ooh, yes, yes, please.
Yes, please.
Oh, wait.
I don't...
I can't.
I'm too good at the game.
I don't need it.
Oh!
I guess he's...
I guess...
Yeah, we're too good at the game.
What's this guy?
You want a way to replenish your shield real quick?
Oh, wait, what?
Oh.
Did that work?
Yeah, I did!
Wait!
Oh, yeah!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, do me, do me, do me!
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Oh,
it's dark in here.
Oh no, our ship It's going down SOS, save our ship for real
though Save our ship Oh my gosh They're like running away
Why is there a friendly fire in this for real?
No!
Oh, I thought that was you No Oh my god Oh wait I guess they
just spawn No, they can't just spawn in I feel like this
like set locations.
Yeah, right.
That they're hiding in.
Oh, I don't know where the heck I am.
Where are we going?
Yeah.
We're just...
Whoa!
New areas!
Let's go up the stairs!
Yeah!
Exercise!
Uh...
Hello.
Whoa!
Nice!
Oh!
It kind of sounds R2D to us.
I was about to say R2D to sound an ass.
Whoa!
Wait, there's some more nades over here if you want one.
I have not been using nades at all, dude.
That's fun.
Okay.
Nailed them.
Don't attack me.
Oh, reload, it says.
It gets mad at me.
See what?
Reload now.
I keep accidentally shooting the corpses, too, because I
don't know when they're dead.
I'm so effed up, man.
Wait, I feel bad.
Some of them are just, like, running away.
I know.
They're scared of eyes.
Oh, man.
Oh, but he shot back.
Oh.
Does anyone see him?
Oh, my God.
I had that one.
No, you didn't.
Oh my god!
Yeah.
You're a bad dude.
Yeah!
Get him in the butt.
There I got him in the butt.
That'll happen to you too if you don't.
Yeah, stay humble.
Oh, what is that?
Abandoned ship.
What is that?
That sounds like a big thing.
I guess they're attacking.
Oh my god!
Oh, we need to get to a life pod.
Oh, okay.
We gotta get to a life pod.
I'm listening.
Wait, what's this?
Is this ammo?
No?
Okay.
The Covenant are destroying the life pods.
Oh, there they are.
We are.
Last door's closing.
Okay, I think maybe we have to get on one of these, or
whatever.
Or no, wait, actually, no.
I don't...
Cortana, help!
I think there's over here, there's an arrow that literally
tells us where to go.
I'm I'm blind We know Oh No Oh shit Tight corners Why is
this Oh wait Wait I'm scared I don't think I'm supposed to
This is just a loop Stop kabe donning me Very bug Let me
Very bug Hey Wait wait Wait I always wanted to do this Hold
on What Hey mint Is it like a machine Hello Hey Hey how's it
going This is how they used to talk.
Hey, what's up?
We have a mission to do, Barrybug.
We can't keep just meeting up like this.
We have a mission to do.
Earth is relying on us.
Oh, whoa.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Where were we going?
Oh, I see a guy, though.
I think we go through here.
I ambush him.
Oh.
Jesus.
Stop it.
Oh, shoot.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh god.
Kobe.
Oh, hey!
I said Kobe.
I'm almost dead now because of that.
Thank you.
You said Kobe.
Literally the last second.
I thought you had gamer instincts.
I thought you could dodge in time.
I totally did.
That's why I'm alive.
Oh, I see.
Oh, look, he's there!
Oh.
Wait, can you...
Oh, wait.
I don't think we can get him.
Because we can't.
Oh, they're coming, though.
I think they're going to come ambush us.
Right?
Okay.
Oh, wait.
There's a guy down here.
I guess Master Chief already...
I guess his name is Master Chief.
He probably already has, like, a reputation.
Did I get him?
Oh.
Get out of here, man.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, my God.
Oh, cute to melee.
Oh!
Oh, there is a melee!
Do we go this way?
I don't know.
Oh, it's not this way.
Oh!
You good?
Yeah.
Oh!
Sorry.
Wow!
Oh, oh, that's you.
Sorry.
Hello.
Hi.
Why do I keep teleporting?
It's strange.
Hello.
Hello everybody.
Kobe, Kobe, Kobe.
Oh wait, hold on, hold on.
Oh, I gotta...
Let me adjust the setting real quick.
Uh oh.
Okay.
Okay, I'm back, I'm back.
Okay, just like that, I'm back.
Welcome back.
Welcome back, gamer.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm all on my own.
Oh shoot, there's two of them.
No, no, no, I'm coming, I'm coming.
I got them.
Oh.
Oh, I got one of them.
Where the heck are we going?
Because you went one way.
I went another way.
I think it probably all meets up at the same time.
Oh, plasma pistol.
Yes, all right.
Chain reaction, baby.
I think you came from over there, no?
So, Cortana, princess.
The deer just lost.
Wow.
The way they die is...
He's so dramatic.
I know.
Okay, drama queen.
Yeah.
Oh.
That almost killed me.
Keep your head down.
There's two of us in here now, remember?
Oh.
Oh, oh.
What do you mean?
Oh, I guess we are low on health.
Uh, health.
Yeah.
Oopsie.
Can we jump over it?
Oh, yeah.
Oh, you can?
Oh.
Yeah.
I'm stupid.
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh we saved him!
We saved him!
That guy!
He's definitely not gonna...
He's not gonna abandon...
Wait, where's me?
I guess the cutscenes just have one master chief.
Whatever.
We're gonna make it, aren't we sir?
I don't want to die out here.
Oh!
Look!
Wait, he didn't answer the reassuring Pat.
Oh, no I didn't make it you guys it didn't make it Wait now
my music is so quiet.
I was just thinking what is that thing lieutenant?
What is it?
Oh, damn it.
She's been hit.
I knew it.
The autumn's accelerating.
Keys is going in manual.
Holy.
It's peak.
Heads up, everyone.
This is it.
We're entering the ring's atmosphere in five.
Oh, here we go.
Are you sure you wouldn't rather take a seat?
We'll be fine.
Oh, my God.
Master Chief in my brain.
He pulled out.
We'll be fine.
Sorry.
A halo planet.
We'll be fine.
You guys, you guys shouldn't be, you guys shouldn't be like
shocked.
You guys should be typing in T-S-K-R.
I saw a couple of those and then...
Okay, okay.
Title drop, title drop.
Chief?
Chief, can you hear me?
Yeah, I'm here.
I'm here.
We're alive.
Can you move?
I can.
Oh my god, our pilot is dead.
Chiefs, can you hear?
Oh, everybody's dead.
Oh my god.
We, they should have...
Wait, did they not wear their seat belts?
What happened?
why did we survive and everybody else did we just built
different oh my god wait they're actually all they're all
dead they died in their seats oh my god yeah there's the
impact there's nothing we could do what do you mean theory
is because chief didn't sit down wait because chief didn't
sit down he flew around the pod when they crashed and hit
every other marine this halo is anti seatbelt everybody
covenant will believe that everyone aboard this life Oh my
god.
We killed them because we have the toughest armor ever.
Wow, this place is beautiful.
Whoa.
Wait.
I'm looking at both graphics.
Yeah.
Me too.
Whoa.
Shooting star.
Make a wish.
I don't think it shoots upwards.
I think that's a fire war.
Wait.
Actually, no, it keeps going.
Yeah.
where's it going uh oh it's fine oh there's another one
maybe that's just like an emergency player yeah
wow wow
what a beautiful planet we've landed on portana you gotta
speak up girl there's like a lot going on yeah can we swim
or are we heavy i feel oh you can you can go i'll go inbound
okay we must be looking for survivors i recommend immediate
oh okay i think it's fine Oh!
Ship!
Evasion?
Wait, are these baddies?
They look bad.
I think they are.
Or maybe we should be hiding so that they think everyone
died in the crash or...
Oh, true, right?
Here, I'm gonna get in this bush.
Just kidding.
Okay, okay.
I'm also...
I'm also hiding.
Oh, they're like landing.
Hold on.
Maybe we should be a little bit together.
Okay.
Hey.
Hello.
there's a wasn't there a bridge over here I'm gonna go oh
there yeah they're oh yeah yeah yeah checking yeah whoa you
can actually see them checking all right this stealth
mission now this is just like Metal Gear Solid man it is
yeah Wow we're like in our element right now I'm sneaking oh
shoot they're taking the bridge that we needed to go on I
think I could snipe oh you want to try It doesn't turn red.
Maybe we go on, well.
I feel like if we shoot one, they're probably going to
scream that R2D2 scream.
Oh, oh, shoot.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Hey, quit.
You're stinking.
Oh, sorry.
I got you.
Oh, they dropped some more health.
i guess that was it oh i'm taking their grenades i like
their grenades all right let's go oh wait there's the two
guys over here wait they have no idea that they're friends
did you grab stuff yeah i grabbed a new gun it has like
crystals coming out of it whoa wait that's sick do they have
one oh i oh oh uh i think you i think you alerted the guards
oh whoopsie is my bad I just I was having fun it's like
homing almost oh the needler is that what it's called the
needler yeah wait I think he has one yeah I'll take it they
call me the needler whoa oh Jesus oh my god why is it
screaming it doesn't hold nearly as many bullets though as
the other one.
Yeah, bullets.
Oh my gosh.
What is going on?
Why are you doing that?
Wait, you get two guns?
Oh, yeah, because, uh...
Oh, they're shooting at you.
Oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh, God.
Oh, is it calling for reinforcements baby?
How is it that you...
Wait, how do you change guns again?
Uh, I just do one and two.
Oh, I'm going to go get my other gun back then okay okay i
wish i wasn't so slow though oh shit oh shit i think we
might actually need to shoot them down
wait this pistol is overpowered it is okay just kidding no i
think you should play whichever one you like to play
oh maybe it is overpowered Are you using it too?
Yeah, I am.
There's a scope on this one.
Oh, yeah.
Dang, okay.
Stick to the pistol.
Oh, you can charge.
Oh, you can charge some of the weapons.
Oh.
Okay.
Huh.
It's the best weapon in the game is what most people are
saying.
Wow, okay.
Oh, they had to nerf the pistol and the sequels.
I see.
There's guys up ahead.
Oh!
I'm sniping them with my pistol.
Me too.
Hopefully.
Ouch.
How did you get me?
Wait, where'd you go?
Dang!
It's like mega good!
Oh my god!
I'm sniping?
Oh my gosh!
Heck yeah.
Hell yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, wait, shit.
I'm running out of ammo, though.
I don't know.
Yeah.
Oh, it used to one-shot?
Oh, my God.
I did one-shot, guys.
Oh.
Where'd you go?
I guess maybe you're just no different.
Oh.
Hello.
I thought you ran back here.
All right.
This is it.
We can't go back.
Oh, where?
Yeah, it's okay.
We can conquer anything with two Master Chiefs by our side.
Lifeboat beat Bacon.
Bacon.
Oh.
Oh no, our guys are getting shot down!
Uh oh, uh oh.
I won't let you die!
I won't...
Master Chief!
Oh my god!
Oh maybe we can't shoot that one.
Ship is shooting at me.
Regroup, regroup, hello.
Hi, fellow humans.
Hello, fellow humans.
We are also humans.
Master chief.
I wonder if there's, like, puzzles.
Yes.
I thought we were the only ones who made it off the pillar
of autumn.
It's a mess, sir.
We're scattered all over this valley.
Call for evac, but I got it.
I thought we were cooked.
You good?
Oh, shit, that's going to do a lot of damage.
I was testing out a grenade jump.
Oh, whoa.
Wait, what else we got going?
Oh, there's supplies and stuff over here.
Ooh.
Yes, perfect.
After I blew myself up.
Oh, shoot.
Oh, oh.
They got shields now.
They've...
Oh, my God.
Oh, oh, oh.
Can we not shoot this one down?
oh my god i'm so bad at aiming jesus don't look it's okay
your name is barrel bug not aiming uh true oh there's some
guys over here on the what is barreled good at barreling
i see the ship wasn't turning red so can we shoot it oh so
what i don't think so i'm good at min so you're good at uh
maiding maiding yeah yeah and i'm good at barrel
oh wow who threw that is there another guy who threw what
something just exploded what are you shooting at oh
get out of here man can't you see we're having a private
conversation Gosh, there's some people.
I know.
Rude as heck.
And...
Another bandit dropping in behind us.
They're trying to flank us.
Another bandit.
Oh, yeah, they're right over here.
They're right over here.
Where we came from.
Hold on.
Oh.
Yeah, take him out.
Woo!
Yeah.
Take him out.
I wonder if he can go on the ship.
Whoa, that'd be sick.
die.
Right?
Oh my gosh.
Whoops.
Yeah.
Oh, they're dead.
They're done, though.
Oh, God.
Wait, it's unfair that the ship attacks us.
I know, right?
I got that.
Oh, maybe we could go here.
Oh, my gosh.
There's another ship landing, though.
Oh.
Oh, why did the music start?
Wait, what happened?
I don't know.
Oh, I'm running out of ammo.
Oh, there's stuff here.
Nice.
And another ship landed.
And more guys are incoming.
More little guys inbound.
Wait, where do you go?
Am I blind?
Yeah.
Hello.
Wait, this guy looks...
Oh, wait.
No, no, no.
Yeah, there's just guys here.
Whoa, whoa.
Let's get out of here.
Oh.
Oh, so many people just talking.
I'm sniping them.
Oh, wait.
Oh, there's coming from everywhere.
Oh, God.
I think they're going to start coming up, no?
Where do they go?
I don't see anyone.
Are they dead?
Maybe?
Oh, hello.
Oh, they're coming
up.
Little guys everywhere.
They're just screaming at us.
Oh, my gosh.
I got caught on green.
Oh, no.
I'm sorry.
I shot you.
Their dodge rolling and everything!
We don't have that kind of movement, do we?
Yeah, I don't think so.
Oh, there is like a radar.
You're right.
Right to the face.
Yeah.
Pelican Echo.
I don't...
Kaka!
Fire Team Charlie.
Okay, so not everyone died.
Just like everyone who was on our ship, I guess we ran.
We were...
really unlucky.
I'm on my way.
Mmm.
More lifeboats.
They're coming in fast.
Yay!
More friends.
Lifeboats make it down.
Right on top of them.
So, Hannah, we need you to disengage your warthog.
Wait, are these a bad guy?
No, these are not bad guys.
No, those are our friends.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Roger Cortana.
Oh, there's a timer.
There's a timer.
Oh.
No, I think that's meters away from us.
right oh my god wait start driving start driving yes oh wait
i'm on the i'm on the thingy here we go baby sorry sorry
don't mind that sorry where are we going now oh i see an
arrow i see an arrow
Okay, there's a blue arrow?
Yeah, I have, wait, it actually just points everywhere.
Never mind, hold on, I think I...
Oh.
Oh, I think I go down there!
Oh, probably, you want to just drop?
Yeah.
Woo!
Oh, I think this was a mistake.
We could just touch, just help me push it, help me push it.
Uh...
Oh, nice, nice, nice!
There we go.
Alright.
You want to drive?
I'm one hell.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right, I'll gun, I'll gun.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hold on.
I think I gotta go here.
I'll take him out.
All right, yee-ha!
Okay.
No, I think we gotta turn around.
Right?
Yeah, yeah, there you go.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, an angle.
Oh, shit.
This cave is not a natural plumbing.
Fuck's crap.
Someone built it.
So it must be loose.
Sorry, sorry.
I gotta get used to the controls.
Oh, God.
formation you guys
you got this okay now nobody can complain about my driving
what oh we're gonna monitor their chatter how do we do that
oh i don't know i guess we just have to be really quiet oh
wait oh
It's probably fine.
I think so.
Wait, you don't want to take the car?
Oh, you got it working?
Yeah, you can jump.
Wait, I lost all my stuff.
Wait, did I pick it back up?
Oh, no, all my stuff is back here.
Oh, wait.
So is my body.
Oh, my God.
You killed Master Chief.
Ah!
Oh my god.
Dude, you killed Master Chief.
Wait, where am I?
Oh my god.
Oh, I have to get on this side.
Oh.
There's two of them.
Oh my god.
About to be.
Wait, how do you turn?
Oh.
Over here.
Very carefully.
Oh.
No!
Get out of the car!
No, I mean, I caught shotgun.
You have to...
Oh, Jesus Christ.
You have to gun.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right.
Wait, why is it so...
Why was yours going so fast?
And mine is like so...
Oh, it goes where you aim.
Oh.
Oh, I'm drifting.
Oh I see!
Oh my god.
Dude, we're humanity's last hope.
Oh I see!
I see!
Oh no!
Oh my god, wait a minute, wait a minute.
Yeah, what do you mean?
Oh no.
You think I'm you?
No, no, nothing.
Say that again, bear.
Say it again.
She's a mad woman.
Yeah!
I'm mad with power.
I'm drifting.
Are you doing your job?
We're in, we're in!
Wow!
Running them over?
Wait, where are we going?
Just keep going?
I don't know.
Just keep going.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
Nice.
Wow, that was sick.
Like, it never happened.
Yeah, yeah.
What a...
Hold on.
I'll run them over.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Do a doughnuts on them.
Yes, yes, yes.
Good job, good job.
There's more guys over here.
Okay.
Oh, dang.
They're tough.
Oh, God.
I'm making it.
All right.
Hold on.
I'm gonna get this guy.
Oh, you got him.
You got him.
Oh, sorry.
Okay, I'll leave the last guy to you.
They're really fast, though.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Thread the needle.
Like, thread the needle.
I don't think this is working.
Oh, wait, no, it worked.
It worked.
I'm sorry for doubting you.
I'm sorry.
Is there anyone else over here?
Oh, there are.
There are.
Oh.
Get them.
Get their asses.
Okay, okay.
I'm getting them.
Thread the needle.
Yep, yep, yep.
Uh, don't be...
Be careful.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh.
Did you hear me die?
Where are you?
Oh, there you are.
I left the car before you fully fell.
I- Did you hear me die?
I was like, no.
Wait, I lost my pistol!
Wait, where did I fall?
Here?
Into the abyss.
I lost everything.
Oh, man.
Um, we lost our car.
Oh, wait, you're right.
It didn't respawn.
It didn't.
Should we reload the checkpoint?
Should we both jump?
Uh, yeah.
Ah!
You good?
Wait, I think we have to die at the same time, no?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's die at the same time.
Okay.
Three, two, one.
What?
Wait, wait, wait, no, we're jumping.
I can't live without this, without Rinto.
Oh my god, there's a bunch of us at the bottom of the...
There's so many bodies.
Oh, wait, there's a guy.
There's a guy.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, wait, they all respawned, Barry.
Oh, no.
It's okay, we beat them once, we can beat them again.
So true.
Just run donuts.
Wait, then what are we actually supposed to do here?
Check this out.
Thank you.
I don't think that's that's not really what I meant, but...
Is that donuts?
Yeah, but I meant like on their bodies.
Oh!
Hold on.
I'll get you in here.
Okay, okay.
There's a guy right there.
Thank you.
Where?
Red the needle.
Oh no.
over here okay oh oh oh okay okay we're taking damage yes i
heard that guy he was like we're gonna die oh there's a guy
in here no i mean like one of these guys yeah the aliens oh
they speak english apparently we speak english what the
surely we could just communicate man you think we got I
think so.
Oh, this is not my pistol!
No, I lost it!
Oh.
I still hear a guy.
Well.
I killed him anyway.
You could handle him.
Yeah, I got it.
Oh, oh.
There must be some mechanism to cross this chasm.
Okay, Cortana.
We're not stupid.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Cortana, we're looking for it, okay?
Yeah, we're looking for it.
I think I found maybe something.
Okay.
You could charge the alien pistol, can you now?
Oh, I think I found it.
Oh.
Something's bleeping.
Beeping.
I'm going to activate it.
Okay.
I think you did find...
Oh!
Oh, cutscene.
I found it.
Nice.
Oh, that's a little...
Oh, nice.
Oh.
And then you'll drive us safely across this bridge with no
rails, right?
The...
Yeah?
I've bulled before.
I bull without the railing.
Oh, hey.
Uh, I guess we go back.
Yeah.
Wee!
Is there fall damage in this?
Yeah, I think so.
Oh, okay.
But I I think that was not too bad of a fall.
Yeah.
Where is this?
I'm grabbing supplies.
Well, maybe not.
Where's our car?
Oh, there it is.
You found it?
Yeah.
I'm riding shotgun.
I'm not going to be responsible for something happening.
Okay, I'm ready to shoot.
Oh, okay, okay.
You want me to drive?
Yep, go ahead.
Oh, God.
You got this.
Okay.
It's literally straight.
It's like the easiest thing you could do.
Why are we going slow?
I'm just making sure we don't fall off.
Go!
Oh.
Is anybody here?
All right.
I'm ready to take them out.
Hello?
Oh my god.
I think we're good.
We should keep going.
I guess we are good.
Okay.
Nice.
Uh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
There's new traffic on the hub and the battle map.
Oh, we got a checkpoint.
Ooh.
Nice.
The captain really gave them hell.
If we can find Captain Rewards and the other survivors, we
will establish paradise on this plan.
it yeah yeah we can live here it's great yeah i would i
would live here it seems like really beautiful good oh you
got this okay oh whoa reunion door what does that mean i
don't know oh maybe that's the next mission it just it went
into the next mission i guess maybe
Wow Wait, there's guys from behind us Oh, okay Wait, go to
the Yeah, I think we gotta cross the river Okay Okay, okay
Ow, sorry, sorry Okay I'm going Let's go
Oh shit Oh, wait, no, we're good We're good, we're good
We're fine Oh shit, this thing has all-wheel drive Are those
bombs?
Oh, you're right.
Wait.
I could blow it up.
I think not.
They're not.
They're not bombs?
Okay.
Oh, okay.
Oh my god.
Structure.
There's already existing home.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, hello.
Okay.
I can take them out.
Wait, this might be a little...
Oh, I'm not getting them at all.
Oh, God.
Yep.
You got this.
Yep, yep, yep, yep, yep.
Yep.
I don't know if we're supposed to...
We're taking them out?
Okay, okay.
Are we supposed to be on the car this entire section?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Why else would they give it to us?
I'm not able to hit these guys, by the way.
I'm just, I'm not able to hit anything, but...
Oh, there we go.
What just happened?
Oh.
Maybe they took cover in that structure.
Oh, okay, okay.
Okay, maybe not like that, then.
Maybe not like that.
Guess like this.
Everywhere my mouse goes, I should be able to kill, I think.
But, you know.
Oh, we're gonna...
Oh, I'm sorry.
Maybe they took cover in that structure.
I don't know if I should drive.
What?
Barry, did you...
Do you believe in me?
I did...
Yes.
Did...
Did Spartacus ever give up?
You're right.
He never gave up.
Spartacus...
I think, probably.
I don't think he did, but I'm not too sure.
I mean, you could go this way.
Yeah, maybe let's change our strategy.
Yeah, yeah.
This is a needle that didn't need to be threaded, but it's
fine.
Yeah.
They're everywhere, they say.
Okay.
This does seem good.
This does seem better.
This is a dozen tree.
Okay.
Okay, we're threading the needle.
Oh!
Hello.
Okay.
We're alive, right?
Barely?
Are you alive?
How did you die?
I think I'm under the car.
Where are you?
Oh, hey.
Hello.
Yeah, I think...
Yeah, they got me.
Well, you're still here.
Yeah.
And we can go into this compound.
Yeah, we'll actually go inside now.
We should search the interior.
Woo!
Okay, get this guy out of here.
There's our friends in here.
Oh, hello friends!
We're here!
What happened?
They blew me up.
Why would they do that?
Hello.
Jerks.
Marines!
Take my stuff back.
Marines.
Was that my bodies?
There I am.
Why would you kill me?
You killed Master Chief!
No!
I killed John Halo!
Oh, we stepped on one of their jerky?
Oh!
Oh, they did have those, okay.
Mmm, that makes sense.
Oh, there's a lot of stuff.
Whoa!
Ow!
Oh!
Hello!
Eh, okay, I guess we mainly saved our guys and we just have
to get out now.
Ow, ow, ow, ow.
get out of here yeah oh wait what was it cute oh yeah don't
they look like little gnomes when they did on the ground oh
what do we do what the hell was that it sounded like bowser
can somebody please make a game and can we voice the enemies
in the game yeah that's not a friend i would love to just
make noises oh hello i don't know how i died what what what
what we'll just go into the mic and be like what what what i
won't let me respawn oh hey wait wait let me you killed them
all barry you killed them did i oh wait did i did it say did
it say no marines left oh i'm back yeah they just said
everybody's dead we didn't save anyone
um i think there are way too many uh there are just way too
many freaking grenades there's there's too many we couldn't
help it i know yeah our bad sorry someone in chat said i've
never had that happen well um yeah someone in my chat said i
forgot they had dialogue for messing up that bad it was me i
died barry your gun makes explosion wait really oh oh wait
what did i do that didn't did my gun oh because yeah i mean
you killed me yeah so oh
where do we go i guess we continue onward maybe yeah there's
no survivor so we could just write the story how we want to
check that out Oh, I took damage for that, though.
Oh.
Well, we just...
It looked really cool.
We just get back on the road, and we just keep on keeping
on, right?
Team!
I guess so?
Hop in, baby girl.
Yeah, I'm coming.
Hold on.
I do think you are better than me at driving.
You think so?
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Which way?
Wait, hold on.
have to take it back hold on where are we going oh i'm
following spaceship
uh oh
they're ahead of us too okay okay okay
crashes make these dogs really bad get it get the get the
ship get the ship okay okay yeah we're good we're good okay
thread the needle Oh, clean.
Oh, clean.
Oh, there's some tricks.
There's some guys.
Marines are concealed in those rocks.
Consumed in those rocks?
So our job is to just be like a hero to everybody that we're
the people's hero.
You know, it's a thankless job, but someone has to do it.
That's a thankless job.
Yeah.
Oh, I see them.
I see them.
I'm going to get our friends.
Yeah, yeah.
Hi, friends.
I'm here.
Master Chief.
Hi.
Chiefette.
Master Chief.
Yeah.
Thank goodness we're here.
We're here to save you guys.
I'm the sexier version of Master Chief.
What the?
Oh, shit.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Oh, there's a guy up here shooting.
Whoa, where'd you get that, buddy?
Yeah, I want a sniper gun.
Mrs. Chief.
Yeah, I want a sniper gun too.
Chief 1 and Chief 2.
Oh.
Where are we supposed to go, actually?
Oh, over here.
Well, I can't ping.
I'm following you.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And...
Oh, hello.
Get your stinking shields out of my face.
Oh, my God.
I'm shooting this guy's shadow.
Alja, stop dodge rolling on me.
Stop styling on me, please.
Alja, smoking, smoking, sexy, style.
Styling.
Style.
Go, it's so...
Stop shooting at us.
Oh, they're about to release more.
He's gonna blow!
Go!
Go away.
Oh shit... Oh shit, oh shit.
Oh my god, oh my god!
Neighborie!
Kobe!
Kobe, Kobe!
Kobe, Kobe, Kobe!
Kobe!
Kobe is... Kobe acknowledged.
Thank you, thank you...
Hey, what's this?
What are you doing?
We have to stay with the Marines.
Oh, sorry.
Oh!
Oh, we have to stay with the Marines.
Now I'm just watching you.
Where am I?
Uh...
Where are you?
Where are those?
Wait, is that you?
What happened?!
I freaking died!
I took your stuff.
I flew too close to this stuff.
I didn't know.
You scavenged me.
Marines, are we okay?
Marines, are we good?
Where are the Marines?
Are we chilling?
Are we chilling, Marines?
Oh, they're back.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
I'm coming.
That's my friend.
Oh, that's my friend.
Wow.
Yeah!
What that you're not dead yet?
I think you're dead.
Uh...
Oh, there's more... There's like health packs and stuff
here.
Get out of here, man.
There's too many of you guys.
That's so cool.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
Yeah!
You can do it to me.
Ouch!
Ooh!
Oh!
Oh, owey, owey, owey.
Why can they dodge roll?
And I can't.
I think our armor is too heavy.
Master Chief isn't that strong.
Let's chill.
Wait, I walked over a sniper rifle.
Wait, really?
Wait, over here?
Oh, wait.
Maybe in here.
Oh, my God.
You can do like 3-16 sniper compilation.
Wait, is it only...
Did you get one?
No, it's okay.
Go crazy, though.
Wait, that might be our team.
I think so, yeah.
Team!
Oh, here they come!
The little people!
Look at all the people!
Imagine all the people!
Wow, we saved four people.
Oh, wait, us two!
Us two!
Hey!
You forgot the chief!
Damn.
Oh my god.
They hate us!
Wait, this thing has like no bullets though.
Wait, they also left some people too.
Wait, what?
Hello.
Did you choose to stay or?
Uh.
Huh.
We have more Marines to save.
Yeah, maybe maybe we missed.
like a huge chunk of them.
Maybe?
We can't get up there.
Damn.
There's also a guy here.
Seeing if they left any supplies up here.
I think...
Oh.
There's something.
A gun.
Oh, we have to go to another place, I guess?
Okay.
Yeah, but where...
How...
Is there?
Oh, there's a thing in the sky.
Oh, that's the people asking for help?
Probably, maybe.
Oh no!
Alright, I'm near the car.
Apparently the NPCs will jump in the car when we get in.
Oh, okay.
Wait, but where do we go?
Get in.
Showtime!
Showtime, he says.
Yeah.
Uh, it was like that way, like around this way.
Yeah, that's what I thought.
Yeah, this way.
Okay, this is where I was trying to go before.
Wait, no, we've killed here.
Yeah, no, we've been here.
This is where we came from.
Right.
Uh...
No, that's correct.
Oh, it is?
Wait.
I don't know.
I picked up reports that the Covenant has located and
secured the Yellow Bottom's crash site.
Good news is that Captain Keys is still alive!
Oh, we are on the right track?
Okay, let's go, let's go.
Oh, okay.
Oh, you've got to backtrack a teeny bit.
Okay, okay.
Okay, gotcha.
This is the main area.
So maybe, like, in through this way?
Yeah.
I like your method of pointing.
In the water we go?
Yep.
Oh, yeah.
All-wheel drive.
All terrain.
Oh, the boobio.
It's fine.
We're okay, aren't we?
Oh, that way.
There we go.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Not bad.
Oh, oh, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Nice.
See?
Good job.
Why would you doubt me?
Oh, I see some.
I see some.
You want to snipe them?
You're the best boss.
Well, you're the one who...
Wait, is that...
actually i can't tell if they're like actually oh hello we
could also go sniping
okay okay oh oh oh no that's people that's people that's
people that's people that's people it's people it's people
it's people okay am i gonna get off yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm
ready to Let's kill.
Oh, wait, that sounds strong.
Nice.
Oh my god.
Uh...
Oh, shoot.
Oh.
Alright.
Call me quiet.
Ham, ham, ham, ham.
Wait.
Oh, oh, right there?
Where was that?
Oh.
Let's all get vocal parasites together.
Whoa!
Ham, ham, ham.
Oh.
Oh, that's you.
Oh, hello.
Look at that.
Everybody's dead already.
Yeah, we did it.
That was easy.
I think there might still be some guys up here.
Maybe?
Oh, probably.
Ooh, the music is kind of...
Ooh.
It really makes you feel like a Master Chief.
I've been chiefing this entire time.
Can we talk about...
What?
I feel like...
I'm scared of what's happening.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Well, actually this might be controversial, but I feel like,
you know, obviously people are used to Master Chief because
he's such an iconic video game character, but like...
Taking the actual name out of context, Master Chief is kind
of like a stupid sounding name, no?
Oh, no, I think I get it.
I think I- because he's like, you can't be a chief and you
can't be the master at chieftain.
It's a military rank- oh shh, like a real- oh shh.
Hmm, uh, sorry.
I didn't mean it, guys.
It's a navy rank!
I didn't mean it.
I have to do it to it.
Just take me out.
Wait, did we save the guys?
I don't know, actually.
This guy's just been chilling in the car.
Oh, I hear a guy.
I hear a guy.
I heard a monkey.
Yeah.
I think I got him.
Oh, you did?
Oh, there.
Wow.
Okay, that was him.
That was just him.
All right.
Okay, easy.
Easy.
He's being held on a covenant cruiser.
The truth and reconciliation.
Truth and reconciliation.
What a name.
We cannot make fun of any military ship names or terms,
guys.
We're on thin fucking eyes.
I'm so fucking scared.
Wait, who do we get to get aboard too?
Hold on, I'll get the car.
I'll get the car.
Oh!
Oh, sorry!
You wanted to bring the car.
A
car left behind.
We did it.
We did it!
Yahoo!
We saved Autumn.
I think the Autumn died.
The enemy has captured Captain Keys and are holding him
aboard one of their cruisers.
The truth in reconciliation.
The ship is currently holding position approximately 300
meters above the other end of this plateau.
Oh, why are we going to this ugly place?
We have to rescue the captain.
Couldn't he be in a nicer place?
I think he's like a prisoner of war.
Oh, shit, we have snipers.
Oh, you got one too?
Let's go.
Oh, my God, we're so bad.
All right, hit it, Marines.
Hit it, Marines.
Hit it, hit it.
Wait, stick to the higher ground to the right?
To the right, okay.
I've detected Covenant stationary guns near the next pass.
Oh, I see something.
I recommend using your sniper rifle to take out the gunners
while I call for marine support.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's so freaking dark, man.
The Master Chief is going to covertly take out as much as
Covenant as you can.
Don't open fire until you hear the enemy return fire on us.
That should let us keep the element of surprise.
Oh.
Um...
Uh, yeah, about that.
They're already shooting at us.
No, right?
How do they see us in the dark?
Take him out.
Oh, we got it.
We got it.
Oh, our target is running.
Our target is running.
I took him out.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
I fell.
I thought you did that on purpose.
Is that a guy?
I can't tell.
It's so dark.
Yeah.
Everything's a guy.
Let's go!
Oh, we had flashlights on.
Oh, there's a...
Oh, there's a night vision.
Nice.
Wait, what's the night vision?
If you are in scope and you press...
Oh my gosh!
You just press 4.
Oh.
Press 4.
Oh!
Yeah, sniping is trying to kill you.
Oh, that's much better.
Wait, are you a friend?
Yeah, you're a friend.
Oh, hello.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Snipe them.
Yeah.
Yes.
Wait, can we...
Are you riding that?
Can we move?
No, no, it's just...
Oh, you can get them, though.
You can get them.
I don't think more are coming.
Yes, they are.
Oh, oh, oh.
Wait, you want to ride it?
I'll lead them to you.
Or you can lead them to me.
I don't think you can ride it, right?
Oh, shit.
No, yeah, you have to lead them.
Where is he?
Get out of here, man.
Oh, my God.
Almost died.
I like their little, like, lighting.
It's very atmospheric.
The music is kicking in too.
Oh my gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god.
Where are you?
Trying to snipe him?
I'm stupid.
Hello.
Get out of here.
Stop, get out of here.
Get out of the way.
They're just monkeying around.
I know.
Wow.
Where are you?
Oh.
That one.
Ew.
Ow.
Oh, the enemies run if a superior officer is killed.
Whoa, whoa.
That's cool.
Or are you going by some of them's run?
Wait, there's...
Oh, wait.
That's the thing from before.
Where are we going?
I'm just running around grabbing things.
I...
I think we go up here.
Yeah, yeah.
Hmm.
up ahead okay all right oh okay we're gonna sneak we're
gonna slash flashlight off oh wait oh oh i'm sorry i pressed
i mean to be fair f is usually flashlight right
i'm not i should not be blamed
Move up on the left.
Oh, I'm almost dead though.
We're killing them.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, wait.
Wait, hold on.
Stop.
Stop running around.
Uh, no.
No, wait.
What?
Alert.
Covenant drop ships are inbound.
Oh, dropships!
No!
Why aren't we already having a rough time then?
I know.
Oh shoot, I'm already in there.
Oh, whoa, what the fuck?
Oh, active camouflage.
Whoa.
What was that?
I picked up active camouflage apparently.
Whoa!
Am I invisible?
Yeah, I want some more.
You want some more?
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
You want some more?
What?
How is that not...
How do I get on the turret?
Wait, where is the turret?
There you go.
Uh...
You just press E next to it.
Ouch!
Don't die!
Oh my gosh, I'm gonna die.
I'm getting to the turret.
Oh my god.
Hello.
Oh, oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh, that's you, sorry.
Hello.
We're directly under the ship now.
Oh my god, you left me with one HP.
Oh, sorry!
I'm so scared.
Wait, I lost everything to get over here and now they're all
dead.
Inside?
To move troops and supplies between the ship and the
surface.
We need to ambush them at the Gravelift's loading zone and
use the lift to enter the ship.
Gravelift loading zone?
What?
What are they talking about?
Uh...
Wait, um...
Hmm...
Is this like something to go in?
The ship that we're right underneath?
Uh-huh.
Oh, I see it!
Over there!
Like...
You see, you see?
Oh!
Okay, okay.
Then I think you have to go over...
Yeah, I think we go through the little... Yeah, I think so.
Okay, okay.
I'm coming!
I'm here.
Tracking your head through my scope.
Dude.
Oh, oh my god.
You got it, my shot!
Why, you victim...
You victim blaming me I'm dead!
Sorry, my bed.
That was just perfectly cut.
I really was.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch!
Ouch!
You can do it, you can do it!
Don't die, don't die!
Are you not back yet?
No, it says we're in for the spawn.
Oh my god, oh my god, okay, hold on.
Wait, I'm gonna get to the turret.
Okay.
No!
They blew up the turret!
You bastards!
Oh my god.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
Where did I die?
Where's my... Oh, here it is.
Where's my sniper?
You got it?
Yeah.
Alright.
Yeah, it was a...
It was a strategic gameplay to...
Obviously.
To reset my HP.
Go!
I'm just shooting anything.
I might be friends.
Die already.
No, wait, hold on.
Wait, are those bad guys?
I can't tell.
Oh, that's you.
Sorry.
It's so dark.
It is so dark.
Who wants a piece of me?
We're dead.
I think I might have just killed a Marine.
He wanted it.
You wanted a piece of him, maybe.
I'm sorry.
Who wants a piece of me?
Man, I think all our friends are dead.
Wait, really?
I don't see him, are we?
I don't hear him either.
I think you killed the last guy.
Who wants a piece of me?
Oh, that's you, sorry.
Hello?
Why are you...
Stop.
Whoa.
What the hell?
this guy do it?
Oh my god, they're never ending.
Do we have to, like, shut something down?
I wonder.
Eh.
Hello.
Going in there does nothing.
Uh, it doesn't feel like anything.
Oh my god.
I'm just chilling in here now.
You gotta kill dudes for a while.
You'll know when you can progress.
Get out of here.
Maybe now?
Maybe?
Checkpoint done?
Checkpoint done.
Oh, there we go.
Okay.
Oh, these guys are big, big guys.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
Whoa!
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Are they throwing stuff at you?
Um, I might have died.
Uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh, uh-oh.
I'm sorry.
I'm leaving.
Oh, my God.
Wait, he's after me.
Yeah, he's like right on your butt.
Oh, God.
If you could just, like, lose this guy.
Oh, you're out of ammo.
Switch guns, switch guns.
I'm trying.
Nice, nice dodge.
Stop.
Oh.
Give me a run.
Keep zooming in on your ass.
I'm not trying to do that.
It's really just showing your ass to me.
Is this safe?
It won't let me in.
Okay, okay.
I'm disengaging.
Oh, oh, oh, okay.
Okay.
My ass.
Your ass, your ass.
Where'd they go?
Where's that guy?
Oh.
Oh, shoot.
No, I lost my sniper.
Okay, it's okay.
Oh, nice, nice, nice.
Oh.
No, my sniper.
Oh, wait, I got my sniper.
Nice.
Wait, it might be mine that I let go of because it was out
of bullets.
You are so right, actually.
Wait, I got my old one back.
Okay.
Is it worth it?
I think you fell off.
Do you see my stuff?
there can you like can we no I guess we can't shoot it into
oh wait there's a help you need a help I should be good
resupply resupplies is this not the end of the level it's a
drop oh no it's reinforcements all right our friends are
here.
Bye, Barry!
Oh, wait.
Barry!
I don't think it was taking us all the time.
Oh, we're going up.
Yeah, we gotta go into the ship, yeah.
Just like in that one K-pop movie.
We're going up, up, up, up, down, down, down, down, down.
Wait, oh, he's too heavy.
He's too heavy.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, all right.
Okay, how do we tell?
Oh, Covenant.
Oh, my God.
There's definitely going to be a boss, right?
All right.
Nobody's here.
This has to lead up to it.
Oh, wait.
I hear somebody, though.
Oh, my God.
Well, what happened?
Oh.
He has the hammer.
He has the halo sword!
Oh, he's dead.
The halo sword.
How are you invisible?
I picked up a thingy.
Oh, nice.
We showed him, yeah, we did.
Good job, team.
Good job, guys.
Nice.
Ah!
Nice shot.
Get out of here.
Oh, I'm gonna go back to my other gun.
Hmm.
Oh, did I walk into a grenade?
I just, like, completely did not notice.
That one?
Yeah, right there.
Ooh.
Oh.
Can we go through, then?
Are we supposed to go through?
I don't know.
I'm in.
Maybe, right?
I'm right behind you.
Can we throw to the destroyer?
Oh, look, yeah.
Wait.
Wait, does this open?
Oh, wait, Kobe, Kobe, Kobe!
Why would you do this?
This one opens.
The red ones don't open.
Oh, gotcha.
Oh, wait, I think we're trapped in here now.
Wait.
Oh, no, it opens.
It opens.
Okay.
Our friends are dying, though, so we might want to...
Uh...
Yeah.
I am seeing some dead bodies.
Almost got...
We have wounded here!
Oh, Medi!
They're wounded and grish!
Oh, shit!
Oh, God, oh, God, oh, God, oh God!
Over here!
Oh, shit!
I'm stuck!
Oh, God, oh, God.
Oh,
I died!
One of ours?
We only...
Yeah, we only have two guys left.
Oh, no!
How many did we come in with?
Like two.
Oh, yeah, okay, okay.
That makes sense.
Yeah, yeah.
No, we didn't lose anybody.
The door's locked, sir.
No way through.
We're the way around.
I think the...
We're gonna sit in ducks in that narrow space.
We can hold this position if you can find a way around and
open the door from the other side, Chief.
Okay, okay.
I think they mean these.
Let's see if we can find a way to open this door.
Hmm.
Oh!
Oh my god!
Get out of here.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Uh...
You got him?
Get out of here.
Eh.
Is this the right way?
Are we going?
Yeah, this way.
Ooh.
Oh, okay.
Oh god, oh god.
Get out of here, man.
Get out of here.
All right.
Did I get up?
Get out.
Eh.
Oh man, I'm up.
Uh.
Wait.
Whoa.
Who's yelling like that?
Kobe, Kobe.
Oh.
I got him?
Yeah, I think we need to open the door, but I don't know how
to get down there.
I guess we just have to...
I think we could just jump.
Or, I don't know, actually, how they want us to do it.
We can jump.
Did you go through that?
No, I think we just go down, maybe, hopefully.
Oh.
Nice.
Yeah, I think none of these open.
Yeah, I think we just go down this way, right?
Yeah, no need to jump.
Oh, hello.
Or maybe it's down here.
Oh, oh.
I'm right behind you.
Okay, okay.
Oh, die.
Okay.
Yeah, we're going the right way.
Right.
I think so.
This feels like a boss area.
It does.
But I think we took care of everyone here though.
Okay.
Our friends?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, my friends.
I don't have any object permanence, man.
I got your back, buddy.
Oh, sorry.
Oh my god.
Oh, where are they coming from?
Get out of here.
Oh, that's you.
Sorry.
I think I just killed you.
I'm sorry.
If this kills you, I'm sorry.
We should get moving.
Where are we moving?
Oh, this way.
Oh, there we go.
If you got Johnson.
What the hell is Johnson?
What does sync mean?
Why is it my chat?
I don't know.
Heal in sync.
Perfect sync?
What does that mean?
Is it a red versus blue reference, maybe?
Oh, hello, friend.
Oh, oh, my God.
I almost shot him again.
Oh.
Incoming.
Oh, nice.
Why are you running?
Stop running.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, it's okay.
I just keep running into fire.
I think we're...
Doing it.
Yeah, I think so, right?
Yeah.
Yeah, we just keep going.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh, what is that?
Oh, oh, what is that?
It's a ship, it's a ship.
A ship on the ship?
There's a ship on the ship!
Oh, that was mine!
Okay, screw it.
Oh, I see it.
Ah!
Oh, it overcame you.
Nice.
We got it, we got it.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, I keep thinking that the beeping noise is like,
grenades.
You got it, Minto!
Snipe them!
Yeah!
Let me snipe!
Love to snipe!
Oh, oh, Mint, there's a power up here.
You think it could be?
I think it might be the shield one, actually.
It was, yeah.
Get it out of here.
I never want to see you guys ever again.
I think our guys need to get covered!
Uh-oh, uh-oh, are they dead?
I heard a not so good noise.
Don't be honest.
No, I'm sure he just stubbed his toe.
Ouch!
Ouch, ouch.
Wait, where are they shooting from?
Up here.
Oh my gosh.
Ow!
Get to the face.
I don't know if I could get those guys up there.
I'm getting them.
Surely there's a way...
Ouch!
Oh my gosh.
Leave me alone.
Nope.
I think all our guys are dead.
I think we lost our...
Oh!
Oh no!
Oh my god, he's like a little spider on the wall.
He's splattered.
Oh my god!
No, no, he's just closing his eyes for a little bit.
I feel like I like the OG better, but the new one is so much
easier to see.
Oh.
Sorry.
Oh, yeah.
It's like so much brighter in the remaster.
Right.
Yeah.
I hear that, but I don't know from where.
Can we like climb up?
Do any of these doors open?
We're going to access the Covenant Battle Net.
and locate an override code to open a door.
Oh, okay.
I think Cortana was sabotaging us, no?
Because she said there was no guys on this ship.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was her fault.
Cortana.
Cortana, out.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna die.
Oh, I missed every shot that you take.
Sometimes you miss every shot that you take, guys.
Sometimes you miss every shot and that's okay.
Yeah.
Let's see.
We don't need any of our guys.
We only need our two selves.
Our master chief selves.
Yeah.
There's two big guys.
But they're not moving.
Oh, just kidding.
I lied.
It's okay.
Oh, there's two.
Yeah, there's two of them.
You said there was two, but...
Get out of here.
Go away.
You got one?
Okay.
Oh.
Where's the other one?
Did you take him?
I think I killed him.
Yeah, I think I killed him.
Let's go.
All right.
I almost shot her again, but she got in my way!
The door is open.
Everyone should move through.
Everyone should move in.
It's us.
Everyone is two people.
Oh, okay, okay.
Nice.
Oh, nice.
More sniper rounds from our dead brethren.
Wait, hold on.
No, they're all...
They're all sleeping.
Don't worry.
Yeah.
Everyone should move through, guys.
Their spirits are still with us.
Oh.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, you're behind me.
Hello.
Don't worry.
Oh, I got your back.
I got your six or whatever they say.
On your...
On your six?
Oh.
I died.
I was reloaded.
You're invisible.
Wait, are you invisible?
I died and he left.
Oh, wait.
There's an invisible enemy.
Maybe that's why.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Hello?
I thought you were invisible for a second.
That's...
I didn't attack him.
No, I didn't get him.
I didn't get him.
Oh, did he run away?
Yeah, I think he keeps moving backwards.
Into the...
deeper you won't get away with this yeah oh maybe he will I
don't know he's here he's here I see him I see him oh no
he's invisible oh I got him nice nice Ouch, ouch, ouch,
ouch!
Eh.
Get out of here, man.
Yeah, get out of here, man.
Get out of here.
What's this?
Oh.
What do we do here?
Do I do these things?
No, nothing with these.
Uh, yeah, I'm actually...
Maybe we should be paying attention to the story more.
I think we're just going.
Oh, here, more.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Whoa!
Woo!
Oh, I keep forgetting.
Ouch.
Get out of here.
That guy just took off.
Just bonking them.
Oh.
Nice, nice, nice.
Checkpoint done.
All right.
Wait, you can activate one of those panels?
Wait, what is it?
What?
Should we go back?
It calls in a horde.
I always forget the melee, yeah.
Oh, that's it, right?
Can you imagine?
Oh, wait.
Did it work?
There's one next to the empty spot.
Huh?
You guys have just been lying to us this entire time.
Guys, if you've never played Halo, you don't have to lie
about it.
It's okay.
You've never played either.
Wait, what?
Oh.
No, it didn't.
You did it.
What?
Oh, press E.
Oh, what?
I'm pressing E.
Nothing happened.
Wait, what?
I pressed E to open...
Oh, pressed E to open...
Wait, you're right.
Yeah, but nothing happened.
I guess it already opened?
I guess so.
Maybe that's why this door opened or something.
Maybe.
The shield on the left dropped.
Oh.
Uh, plasma rifle?
Oh, maybe I should grab one.
Oh, oh, oh, hey.
Hey, you.
Yeah, get him.
Get him.
Oh!
Ah!
No!
I didn't notice.
Yeah, I didn't notice.
Nobody called Colby.
He didn't.
He's such a bad team player.
I know.
Oh, because you had Marines with you, you didn't think.
you need a reinforcement.
Wait, what?
What'd you say?
I don't understand.
Yeah, I don't...
He's gone!
They're so funny.
What came first?
The Bryant or the me?
Is this anything?
What came first?
The who or the what?
Oh, who's shooting at us?
Were you?
Oh, yeah, there's guys behind us.
Oh, this is.
I don't want to repeat it because my chat is giving me minus
twos.
I don't think I should repeat it.
What did you say?
They didn't like my joke.
Haters, haters, haters.
Haters, man.
I bet.
if Mint heard it, she would have at least given me a pity
laugh.
No, say it again.
Say it again.
No.
What came first?
The Bryant or the meat?
You get it?
Because Kobe...
Was Kobe Bryant?
Oh, a Kobe bean!
Thank you.
I got it after it was explained to me.
Oh, oh.
What the hell?
Oh shit, I awakened them.
Oh my god.
I didn't...
Ah!
Oh, I took them out.
Smash me.
Stay alive, Minto.
You're alone.
I am?
Wait, how do I activate you?
I think you have to disengage, maybe?
So I have to...
I can spawn...
Disengage?
What does that mean?
Oh, there you go.
Hello.
You just have to go away from the combat a little bit.
Sword is one hit kill.
Jesus.
I want that.
Oh, I got him.
You're safe.
Oh, sorry.
I hit you again.
It's okay.
Mint raining bullets at my back.
I know.
It feels like a massage.
It is.
It's supposed to be meant like that.
Yeah, yeah.
Dude, oh my god.
I think this way.
When you... I've not been to massages that often, but I feel
like every time I've gone to a massage, it hurts so...
much but then i'm like i try not to be a big baby about it
but it always backfires on me that's what they're supposed
to hurt though that's how you know it's working good but
then you wake up later and you're just like
that's exactly how it feels getting a massage you guys
wait wait oh oh this way this way this way Uh-oh, I'm
running out of bullets on this thing.
I gotta grab new guns soon.
Got, we need more guns.
More guns.
Oh, more guns.
I don't know.
Massage is hurting.
Like, obviously I don't say anything because I don't, you
know, want to seem like a big baby, but I feel like they're
not supposed to hurt.
No, they are.
That means they're getting deep in your tissue, no?
Oh, shoot.
I'm almost...
But then, like...
Uh-oh.
I'm out of ammo.
Uh-oh, uh-oh.
You can pick up this thing they have here.
Yeah, that's what I'm gonna do.
This guy.
Alright, cool.
What if they what?
What if you, like, wake up and it just, your body just aches
for, like, the next, like, week or something?
I mean, you pay for it, right?
I pay to get hurt.
You pay to get hurt.
Poor.
Oh!
This looks like a...
This looks like a spooky room.
Holding cells.
Wait, where are they?
multiple detention stations.
The captain must be in one of them.
We need to keep looking for him.
Wait, there's a guy!
Master Chief is in here!
Oh!
Wait, if you activate it, will I be put in jail?
Try, try.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
We're finally putting Mint in jail.
Oh, no, I can't activate it.
We can RP like it's activated.
Oh, okay, okay.
Let me out of here!
Ah, that's what you get for killing...
I'm killing five people no I did the crime but I won't do
the time I won't do the time what yeah I'm I got my spoon
over here I've been digging for days you'll never catch me
alive you'll never catch me alive when you're in prison we
gotta send you to Alcatraz oh this guy has a bunch of stuff
over here by the way oh oh nice yeah sorry I grabbed some
stuff already We finally caught Mint.
Wait, does this guy have any shit?
I thought they were asleep.
I didn't realize they were dead.
I know your crimes.
You've killed people.
I know your other moniker too.
Jack the Ripper.
Whoa!
I've killed and I will do it again.
No!
Lock her up.
What the hell?
I'm prepping this.
Why is there so many guys there?
dead around here actually isn't this where we came from it
might be oh is it oh i think you're right i think they did
find out the identity of jack the ripper like a year ago or
something right like recently no who was he was he just like
a random doctor guy wait i don't remember yeah because there
were so many guys that i feel like people were saying that
he could have been oh wait no we came from here yeah where
do we oh maybe down here then people in chat are saying me
what the you wait like get out like they're saying them we
have jack the rippers in chat nice jack is back jack is back
jack is back oh gosh there's a big baddie guy here oh oh
this must be the other prison okay i'll snip him i'll try
and snip him okay okay oh shoot sorry well that's awkward oh
oh oh oh oh oh Okay, I open the door again.
Where'd he go?
I'm opening the door again?
Yeah, I know.
I don't see him, though.
Oh, there he is.
There you go.
Got him.
Nice, nice.
Okay.
Oh, there's an invisible guy.
There's an invisible guy.
There's a couple invisible guys.
I'm throwing.
I'm just throwing grenades.
Ah!
Oh.
The shit.
I hear him.
Oh, he's just chilling.
Oh, he is.
Wow.
Yeah, he's just chillin'.
Wow, okay.
Alright.
Nice!
Hi!
Alright, I'm gonna let him out.
Hello!
Just kidding.
Coming here was reckless.
You two know better than this.
Oh!
You too!
Whoa!
Acknowledgement!
Yeah!
Marines, lock and load your weapons.
Let's be ready to move.
Oh my god, it's so freaking dark in here!
I can't see anything.
us locked up in here i overheard the guards talking about
this ring world they call it halo one moment sir accessing
the covenant battle net oh my god wait we're on halo the
ring has some kind of halo is the planet oh wait if i'm
analyzing this correctly they believe that halo is some kind
of Oh.
Oh.
That's true.
It's like how they need Metal Gear Metal Gear.
Yeah.
Controls the fate of the universe.
I have intercepted a number of messages about a Covenant
search team scouting for a control room.
I thought they were looking for the bridge of a cruiser that
I damaged during the battle above the ring.
But they must be looking for Halo's control room.
Halo's control.
That's bad news.
If Halo is a weapon, combat has evolved.
They'll use it against us and wipe out the entire human
race.
Wait, then if they, well, we know that they don't because we
got Halo 2 and 3 and 4.
Well, no, it could happen after the apocalypse.
We don't know.
Marines, let's move.
It's like how they made more Metal Gears after the first one
was.
Oh!
You have the point.
Oh my god.
Shut up and get behind me, sir.
What someone just said.
Okay, fine.
We should head back to the shuttle bay and call for Evac.
All right.
We have to make sure we don't kill this guy.
I will not shoot this.
Oh, no!
Oh, I don't know where they are.
Where'd he go?
It's so dark.
I'm going into...
Oh, there he is.
There you go.
Nice.
They're strong.
Okay.
Together we stand.
Okay, I've gone into a better graphics mode.
so that I can see better.
Okay, okay.
Mint carry.
Nice.
Okay.
So we can't go...
Spread out!
Oh, you're fine.
I don't think we should do that.
I like that they're...
Oh, oops.
I almost...
I just...
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Wait, did I grab yours?
Do you grab mine?
Wait.
No, it's okay.
I dropped it.
This way, this way.
Go, go, go, back to the shuttle.
Oh, shoot!
No, no, don't die!
Don't die!
Don't die on us!
Oh.
We will not let you die!
Dang, okay.
I don't know how to use this one.
Wait, did we not go the way that we were going?
Uh, it was...
We were going to the other prison.
No?
The...
I don't know if this is the right way.
Oh.
Sorry.
Sorry, mister.
Watch out.
Uh-oh.
You got me?
Bag me up.
Come on.
Sorry.
That was loud.
I'm out of ammo.
Let's find him.
Uh.
I don't know what the heck this is.
No, that doesn't open.
Oh, oh, oh.
Uh, this is just where we came from, no?
So...
we have to return we have to bust out bust out we're busting
out we're busting okay okay maybe this way oh that oh yes
maybe maybe wait uh where is this this is new room wait no
it's not oh is this we've been here we've played these games
before oh i just used the terminal Activate Terminal 3 on
the Truth and Reconcil- Uh, there is a...
Do you not have the cutscene?
Oh god, oh god, oh god!
No!
Oh my god, wait, it is an escort mission!
Oh no, I'm in the cutscene!
Oh.
Oh, okay, yeah, we can't let him die.
Oh, no!
Okay.
Oh, you were in a cutscene?
Yeah, it was a literal cutscene.
Oh, whoa.
Spoilers even.
Okay, wait.
Let's clear the room, let's clear the room.
Yeah.
Holy cow.
Oh shit.
Are you dead?
Ah!
That's the skills and the the...
Oh my god.
Skills and pain.
Freaking swords are so good.
Death rattle.
Okay, hold on.
I'll use my sniper on them.
Oh, it's an anniversary spoiler thing.
Don't let don't let her do the cut.
Oh, it's like still playing.
It's like still playing.
I got one.
Nice!
Good job!
How was I supposed to know that it was a spoiler thing?
Oh no!
Oh, it's for returning players to add content.
Oh, they're like still talking.
I'm not listening, you guys.
I'm not paying attention.
Uh-oh.
Acknowledge Toho hammer.
Cortana out.
They're like...
Air support is cut off, Captain.
We need to hold here until she can move in.
Oh, air support.
Okay, we have to...
Yeah.
We're trapped in here.
Okay.
They're working on it.
Audio jungle.
Is it, like, overlapping audio?
Yes, everything is happening at once.
I can't hear anything.
Oh, my God.
It's so terrible.
Is the Covenant dropship still docked?
Um.
Oh.
Oh, oh, oh.
What's happening?
Okay.
Oh, let's go.
Let's go.
Okay.
I dropped it.
Too big.
All right.
I'm going to try and snipe things so that our guys don't
die.
Okay.
Okay, okay.
Sounds good.
Uh, any big guys around?
Uh.
I don't see...
Oh, wait, there's a thing.
We gotta go over this way, you know?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
All right.
All right, team, let's go.
Team, they're all behind us.
Let's go, team.
What just happened?
Oh, that was weird.
I think they're...
Yeah, they're following.
Whoa.
All right, I guess we're just getting out now.
Let's do it.
I think I use it.
Oh, hello.
Oh, you used it?
Let's go.
I think so.
Oh, we're gonna steal their ship!
Oh!
Ooh!
Wait, what if we...
What if we...
What if there's other Master Chiefs who try to shoot us
down?
Give me a minute to interface with the ship's controls.
And then...
I think we're two of a kind, Mint.
I think we're two of a kind.
Okay.
Oh, wait!
Uh-oh, hunters!
try and snipe them maybe oh okay just kidding i think he
just ran them over whoa sir oh my god wait what just
happened wait so we don't have to do anything else we're out
let's go i guess it was all clutching let's go i thought we
were gonna have to like defend the area while they set it up
no nice yeah we got off the truth and reconciliation what a
what a cute like i Oh shit.
Oh, wait.
Oh wait.
I think we're doing the thing that you thought we were going
to do.
Wait, maybe?
Oh, no.
Wait, where are you, Barry?
I don't see you.
I only see other men.
It's over.
I was only in your head.
No, no.
There was always two.
Oh, god.
Oh, it's hot.
It's hot.
LZ is hot.
Pequod.
Help.
Hit it, Marines.
Let's go.
Oh, my God.
That guy, like, actually attacked me.
Oh, you were on the other ship.
Oh.
There was two ships.
That's cute.
We were on another ship than these.
That's so cute.
Yeah, we were like holding hands in ship form.
Uh oh.
Wait, there's a bad guy, big guys.
Big guys?
Oh god, oh god.
Is this the pistol?
Oh wait, I forgot.
There we go.
I forgot to change the graphics back, guys.
You are stuck on advanced graphics.
I know.
I was like seeing followers and everything.
I know people were yelling at me.
They were like, please, please, please.
And you, Minto, I can't see more than one pixel.
Wait, this was the demo level.
Oh, that's fine.
Oh.
It's a beach episode.
Yippee!
Let's go into the water.
Let's go into the beach.
Oh my gosh, don't splash me with my shirt on.
This white shirt on.
Oh my god!
Moon death!
We got another car!
Whoa, hey, wait a second.
Wait, everybody just got in.
Wait, there's no room for us.
Go!
Get out!
Okay, let's move out.
Let's go find a map.
Wait, are they coming with us?
I think so.
Are they not on?
No.
Oh, whatever.
Oh, well.
We got one guy.
One guide.
One guy.
He's got us.
Is he gonna shoot?
Good one.
This is like a sleep man.
I know what you're doing.
I know what are you doing?
Like, whoa, whoa, what's going on over here?
This is a beautiful planet.
It is, right?
In the cliff wall.
Are you shooting or him?
I was shooting, but I think he's also occasionally shooting.
Yeah, he kind of sucks.
Silent cartography.
What is this?
Oh, nothing.
Never mind.
He's doing his best.
Oh, shoot.
I'm almost out of...
Oh, that's you.
Sorry.
Hello.
Get out of here.
Oh, wait.
I don't want to...
Yeah.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah, get him.
Get him.
Dang, did you just shoot?
I just bonked him on the head right now.
My analysis is...
The covener.
Bottom floor.
All right.
Let's keep going inside.
Okay, that's where we're going.
Don't let them lock the door.
Oh no.
No!
They locked the doors.
I'm gonna do it, Barry.
No, don't, don't, don't!
Cortana to keys.
Help.
Did we mess up or do they always lock the doors?
Right.
We gotta, we gotta die.
We gotta start from the checkpoint.
Yeah.
We can't proceed unless we can disable this installation
security system.
Oh, they always lock the door?
Okay, okay.
Okay.
Check this out.
I'm gonna hit the seal.
You're like the guys in school who would always touch the
top of the doors.
I literally had this conversation on stream like the other
day.
I was like, why do guys do that?
I guess if I could also reach the top, I would also do that.
Yeah, probably me too.
I'll stay on station and keep an eye out for Covenant focus.
Okay.
Wait, shoot.
I missed that whole conversation.
I think there's...
sending us help for something but also maybe are you sniping
yeah but with my pistol okay security override they have no
idea they have no clue what's happening did where are they
did you just kill every oh i don't have ammo
okay we i've lost all i'm out of ammo with that one though I
don't want to give it up, though.
I don't want to give it up.
Yeah, I know.
It's so strong.
Yeah.
What the heck is this thing?
I guess we have to just look around for the security
override.
Oh, you went down.
Okay, I'm coming.
Yeah, I'm just exploring.
Ouch.
Okay.
We could bring the car, but I don't know where we left it.
What do you got?
Um, car?
Any cars?
Oh, yeah, where's the car?
Oh, the car's up there.
Oh, I wonder if that guy's still alive.
Oh, probably, right?
Probably.
Yeah, let's go get our car.
Wait, watch this.
I'm gonna freaking do a grenade jump.
Shit, I missed that.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
Let me do it again.
Okay, here we go.
Wait, how do you do it?
I mean, obviously, you don't know how.
Okay, here I go.
Here I go.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
We got it, we got it.
Hold on.
This one, this one.
Ah!
Did it work?
No!
Does it not work?
Do it under the car, then get in?
Oh!
What was the wrong grenade type?
Never mind, my bad.
I don't think we have a regular grenade.
Hey, buddy, don't you...
You're still here, wow.
Wow, he's just chilling.
Oh!
Oh, wait, I don't...
Did we kill him?
We gotta
leave the...
We gotta leave the scene.
We gotta try a minute.
I need you on the gun!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Ah!
I keep pressing F accidentally.
Wait, where is that?
Oh, you got it.
You got it.
Okay, okay.
Wait, I have frag grenades!
Hold on, I could do it.
Wait, watch this, watch this.
Hold on.
Did that do anything?
Wait, no, I'm on this freaking passenger seat again.
Hold on.
Oh.
Okay, okay, okay, we're good, we're good.
There we go.
Yeah.
Oops.
I don't think we're playing this game like we're supposed
to.
Oh.
Okay.
We are always winning though.
We are.
We are winning.
We don't need a third guy.
He was actually hindering us.
So...
Dude.
Yeah, this was a...
Oh, this is a private occasion.
What is this?
Oh, wait, another gun!
Oh, there's guys on our left.
Oh, there's a lot of them.
Take them out!
I don't know if I can get them.
The log might be covering them too much.
Uh-oh, you're all good.
Can I get them?
Yeah, you got them.
Yay!
Yeah!
Alright.
Yeah, get them out.
Okay, anyone might be everybody.
Yeah, yeah, nice.
Do you guys have any ammo?
Oh my god!
These guys didn't even last like two feet from their ship.
Come on.
Oh, from the car.
It's a car.
They flipped it too.
We could have two cars!
Let's go!
Oh my god, we could race.
Hey, nice truck.
Hey.
Let's turn this into a multiple vehicle collision.
Oh god!
Wait!
Get away from me!
Okay.
Yeah, I'm getting some sick air.
Monster trucks.
What do you want, Ted?
Okay, this way, this way, this way, I promise.
I gotta start brake checking mid, dude.
Wait, are there guys here?
They're all dead.
Did we?
Oh, we went around that island.
This is where we came from.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, is it?
Oh, Jesus.
My vehicle's hot.
Yeah, you're right.
This is where we came from.
Where do we go then?
I guess.
Oh, oh.
Turn back around and go back there.
Wait.
Okay, okay.
Yeah, it's a full island.
Wow, okay.
Hmm.
Oh, where we found the dead guys.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, let's go back to the log.
up that way yeah that sounds good yeah yeah baby i'm coming
thread the needle my bud are you threading the okay that
didn't sound like you threaded the needle right here right
here oh god thread the needle hold on i'll help you oh it
might be no we can do this wait No, we can do it.
Two girls versus a tree.
Yeah.
Wait, I just heard somebody.
I heard a minion, I think.
Oh, yeah, they're coming.
Oh.
All right, maybe it's impossible for the cars to get
through.
Oh.
Leave them down here.
Oh, okay.
You're going far.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I'll leave them.
No, you're good.
You're good.
Oh.
Get
out of here.
out of here oh yeah running your little babies you freaking
babies yeah you guys should be saying banana and helping
grew not doing this stuff i think they say banana right they
do know oh yeah yeah yeah banana oh i see a red dot on our
thing oh dead guys dead friends banana no banana
Why don't we have...
Like, our snipers anymore.
Yeah, I liked our snipers.
Oh, nice.
I took that guy out.
Ow!
Ah!
Jesus!
They're, like, launching stuff at us.
I died.
Sorry.
You died?
Oh, it's okay.
It's okay.
Yeah.
Okay, that guy's dead.
We should be good.
Yep, I'm back.
Hello.
Let me grab my stuff.
Oh, there's overcharged shields here too.
Damn.
What's the second gun that I have?
Oh, this guy.
I'll take this.
Yeah, there's the shields.
Nice air.
I know, right?
Is this where we're supposed to go?
I want this gun.
I think so.
It has to be, no?
Or...
No, I think we go.
Oh, I see some guys.
I see some guys.
Oh.
Hello.
all right wait don't they have the can you go inside oh they
probably do oh that's okay oh never mind we can't go inside
here wait where are you what the hell oh shoot uh there's
like a million guys over here kobe kobe oh nice kobe yeah
i'll do it too oh i did not do that yeah yeah uh oh
Okay, okay, nice.
All right, well, if I were somewhere to go, where would I
go?
If I had to go somewhere...
Needler.
Um, I think we're on the right track, going this way, no?
Hmm...
Oh, wait.
Oh, yeah, there's guys, there's guys.
More control, more control.
Get out of here.
Oh shoot.
Wait,
this does...
Maybe if we could find an opening.
Oh wait, look at this.
Oh yeah, here's the opening.
Oh.
All right.
Oh, this is too.
Nothing.
Hacking them.
The alien tech hacking.
Oh, okay, I guess we just go down.
Go down, yeah.
To the secret cartographer.
This looks like a boss room.
Oh, they haven't really had, like, boss or boss.
Yeah.
Oh, shoot.
He's after me.
Yep.
Where'd that guy go?
Oh, nice.
Ah!
Oh, you got...
Okay.
Yeah, we got him.
We got him.
Woof.
Checkpoint done.
All right.
Yeah.
that guy in two hits before that was crazy maybe shot maybe
he has a weak something yeah if you hit the orange skin okay
okay whoa what's oh use the hollow panel to shut down the
security system oh i did it we did it we can one hit them
wow good that should open the door that leads into the main
shaft watch out for that guy yeah watch out for him I want
his sword.
It kind of looks like my cat.
Oh, activate the map room.
You think he's coming after us?
I'm scared.
I feel like he is, no?
Right.
He saw his friends and he's like, how could this happen to
them?
Wait, so...
I need to kill the master.
Oh, yeah!
Sorry.
You're good?
I thought I saw this glass.
Oh.
They are a little...
They're not much...
Much easier to see.
I'm freaking blind.
I'm blind.
I got them.
Nice.
Do we just keep going or...
I think so.
Maybe.
Alright.
Oh, wait, this is where we go.
Yeah, but...
I guess we're supposed to help.
Bravo 22 was bringing us some heavy weapons.
After I saw we were up against hunters, I thought you could
use them.
Oh, thanks.
Oh!
Let's move down the beach.
Keep an eye out for any cargo we can salvage.
Uh-oh.
Did you die?
Ah!
No, I...
Ouch.
Ooh, took some heavy damage.
Oh.
Okay.
So...
Is this the ship that crashed?
That was like Mayday, Mayday.
No!
I think so, maybe.
Oh, they're all dead.
They're all dead.
Wait, what is this?
Oh, what did I just...
Oh.
They did drop some heavy weapons.
A railgun!
No way!
A rocket launcher.
Whoa!
Is it this way?
Oh.
No.
Where is...
Oh, maybe you grabbed it.
Nice.
Maybe there's only one.
Yeah, I guess there's only one.
That's okay.
You want to try?
No, it's okay.
There's only three...
There's only three bullets left, so I think you could just
try.
I don't know if there's, like, a lot of...
I don't...
I actually don't know what they want us to do now.
Because...
They said they...
They wanted to give us heavy weapons, and now we have them.
I mean, we did turn off the security...
So maybe we go back to the place we were at before.
Oh, let's drive there.
Oh, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah, I think that it...
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah, the door got unlocked.
That makes sense.
Yeah, yeah.
You drive.
I don't know where it is.
I'll do my best.
I'm going.
Uh, I'm guessing if we just go around the outskirts, it
should pop up.
Yeah.
Suppressing fire.
Someone just said you should rock.
rocket jump.
Wait!
Oh wait, wait, we'll do it.
We'll do it over there.
Okay, okay, okay.
A rocket jump into the higher, into the higher plane.
We was here, right?
Oh, maybe.
Oh, oh, nice landing.
Stick it, stick it.
Thank you.
Okay, here we go.
Oh my god, wait, this is gonna be awesome.
Hold on.
Oh yeah, yeah, do it, do it.
Okay.
I'm going.
Oh, hi, Raider.
My chat's telling me no.
No?
Oh.
It worked!
You want to try?
Yeah, yeah, give it to me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's right here, it's right here.
Oh, oh, oh.
You got it.
Your turn, your turn.
I'm going to get up there for sure.
You got it?
What do you do?
You just do it?
You just jump?
Nice.
We're masters at it.
Oh, wait.
Where'd my pistol go?
Oh, it's over here.
It's over here.
Apparently you need shields for it, but...
Oh!
Sorry.
I didn't know we were so close.
Oh, wait.
There's still...
There's guys up there.
I wonder if I can grab them.
Oh.
Oh, wait.
I'll drive.
Yeah, get us closer.
Oh,
oh, there we go.
Yeah, it's a big boy too.
Nice, nice.
You might want to move.
Oh god, oh god, oh god.
Oh yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ah!
Ow.
Oh, nice.
You're getting them?
I'm shooting the orange skin!
Nice, nice, nice.
Shoot the orange skin!
Do the Ourski!
Yeah, run into it!
Run into him!
Or us!
Oh!
Yeah!
We did it!
This is why we got the launchers?
No, they give us a car.
Yeah.
Who cares about a launcher?
The car is the strongest weapon.
I know.
Unlimited ammo.
There's a gun on top of it.
Yeah.
oh oh what was that it's open yahoo we're so freaking oh
what's happening shafted oh oh what's up oh oh oh oh whoa
wait i'm gonna i'm going to whoa i'm in i'm in oh oh oh are
there guys where are you where are you i'm behind you I'm
coming.
Okay, okay.
It's so dark.
Holy cow.
Where are you?
Oh.
Hello.
Uh.
What do you see?
They're everywhere.
They're like actually, it freaks me out that they actually
talk in English.
I know, right?
Yeah.
What does it spell out for the greater lore information?
What if, what if we're, actually just crazy and these are
all people maybe we have a really good translator built into
our helmet or something oh maybe actually oh okay that's
where that goes okay i'm reading their maps i'm i'm gaining
there's a secret cut scene secret cut scene if you go back
to the outer shaft hmm I think we, if we missed it, it might
be doomed.
Yeah, sorry.
We didn't know the secret of the secret cut scene.
Yeah.
Oh, dang it.
Um.
Wait, can you see me in here?
Can you see me in here?
Uh.
Oh, you went back down.
Let me see.
No, no, no.
I'm coming.
Hello.
No, turn off your light.
Oh, okay.
Can you see me?
Oh, what the?
You're like hiding like Mecha Chameleon.
Wait, go in, go in.
I want to see.
Okay, okay.
Ooh, that's pretty good.
That's pretty good.
Your lights kind of give it away, but yeah.
Oh.
Barely.
I'm bugging out.
I'm bugging out right now.
I'm ghosting out.
I'm going ghost.
Oh, oh, shit, that's a person.
I can never tell who our enemy is.
Oh, no, there's dead guys in here.
Our friends.
Dang.
Could you...
Get the orange skin!
Oh.
I can't see orange skin!
He died.
That's fine.
Oh, okay.
Hey.
Oh, our dead friends.
Our dead brethren.
rest in peace rest in peace why'd you say it like that like
what you said it like so as if maybe you were behind
something no no no no no no suspicious oh no we got two
enemy dropships coming oh no they're probably gonna I I
wonder, I mean, they'll probably introduce more enemy types,
but I wonder who we're missing.
Because I feel like we have...
There's got to be big guys coming in.
Yeah.
We have the small guy, and then we have the medium guy, and
then we have the really big guy.
We'll be in a tight spot if we don't get out of here before
additional reinforcements.
They have beautiful architecture.
Oh!
Hello!
What the?
I didn't even notice!
Oh!
Whoa!
I didn't even notice that there were enemies.
I was just chilling.
Oh my god, there's so many of them.
Oh!
Oh god, oh god.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
You good?
Ah,
ah, ah.
Thank you.
You saved me.
I owe you my life.
There's another guy down here.
Oh, hello.
Yeah, smack him.
Smack him.
Smack him!
Oh my god, we're painting the walls!
Oh my god, we're painting the walls purple!
They needed a...
Oh my god!
Redecoration.
Master Chief, I didn't know you were so brutal like that.
Didn't anyone hire a remodeler?
Oh, I hear guys.
He's a big interior designer.
What is that?
Reversed.
guys that has to be something right no i think they're
speaking english kind of like oh there's a thing here if you
want it oh and then i can rocket wait watch this i'm gonna
rocket jump
you guys said with the overcharged shield that it would be
okay
wait you guys said i had the overcharged shield
Oh, I can use it.
Okay.
How to jump?
I did jump.
Oh, nice.
I activated something.
Halo's control center is located there.
That structure appears to be some sort of template.
Oh, you haven't jumped, though.
I did jump.
Also, like, the beat of silence that you had was, like,
almost more insulting than if you had just laughed.
Or there's...
They're dead.
Keep trying.
Or they're dead.
Or they all tried rocket jumping.
They all tried.
They heard.
They heard wrong.
We'll be heading there as soon as we're topside.
Man.
Full hammer out.
Wait, okay.
How do we get out of here?
I think this way, right?
Yeah, this way, this way, this way.
These freaking retro games with no markers and pointers,
man.
Oh, oh, oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Where's my yellow paint?
Yeah.
Oh.
Oh, this is...
Oh my god.
Yeah, this is Halo music.
Oh, this is.
This is what plays if you get MVP on CSGO.
Is it really?
Yeah, you can equip the Halo soundtrack.
CSGO?
No!
Who is shooting?
Oh my god.
Whoa, I've never heard more than, like, the first five
seconds of this song.
It's awesome.
Banana ow!
Where'd you go?
Uh.
Wap, wap, wap.
Oh, I see.
I was just...
Oh, you went around.
Okay, I got you.
Yeah, I just went around.
Let me come back.
That's why I was fighting.
No, no, I'm coming towards you.
I was fighting that guy.
Well, I feel like maybe we could go down here.
You think so?
I don't know how to get out.
Yeah, I don't know.
Oh, maybe this one?
Is this anything?
No, we've been down.
Yeah, this is where we came through.
And then...
Whoa.
Oh, this is the...
Oh, guitar.
Ooh.
Let's go back around.
Let's go back to over where that guy was.
Let's...
Barry, I forgot to...
Wait, you gotta come up here.
Yes?
You gotta go up here.
Okay, okay, okay.
I forgot!
I like your cover!
That you did.
Oh!
Thank you!
Yeah, I'm so cute!
Thank you.
What are you covering?
What are you covering in Monogatiri's song?
I don't know.
I did one for my birthday last year.
Does that count?
Oh, sure.
What about this?
this year oh shoot
this year well to be honest you've been yeah oh sorry you've
been so busy this summer yeah like i actually can't believe
how busy you were yeah but it should slow down soonish yeah
and then you can reap your the rewards of your hard work
well don't forget that sword guy is around here.
Oh, right!
A little Chekhov's sword, I guess.
Oh, that was so alive.
Let's see.
Wait, are we going the right way?
Wait, I'm here?
Wait, I don't think we've ever been here, but...
Have we?
Oh, wait, this way?
Oh, up, up, up, up.
Yes.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up,
up, up, up, up.
I think he's in here.
Uh.
I mean, if we keep wandering, we'll find the way we're
going.
We have to find it eventually, right?
Yeah.
Oh, wait.
I remember this room, but... Wait, did we go in a circle?
Uh-oh.
Oh, shoot.
Hello.
I got you.
Wait, oh no, we did go in a circle.
There's no way because we kept going up.
No.
I think we also went down at some point.
Wait, it's sort of an upward spiral.
Wait, we're almost out?
No, yeah, we're finding them.
We're good, right?
Just keep going up.
Just keep going.
Everything leads up.
Okay, keep going up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Oh, this is the right area?
Okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Wait, um...
Do we just go back out?
Out?
Left now?
Oh, do we legit just go?
back outside wait where is that where's outside is it here
oh here yeah oh oh he's here he's here oh oh you got him you
got him he was so easy got him no sweat bozo oh we're trying
to leave i see yeah that's what we are we're trying to leave
yeah i didn't realize because uh we activated that side
requesting pickup oh wait oh invisible guys invisible guys
oh kobe nice nice nice i think they're dropping more guys
and they're invisible i think i think i just saw them drop a
guy he was big and invisible big and shaming oh oh this is
not wait this is us this is our ride this is our ride just
kidding maybe you got scared by our the our ship's aura yeah
and whatever whatever we're boarding let us in let us in a
pelican oh uh all right oh oh wow look at us sitting here
are coordinates in a flight plan these coordinates are
underground oh oh the covenant did a thorough seismic scan
in my analysis shows that halo is honeycomb with deep
tunnels which circle the whole ring wow it's so weird to
hear uh halo being used as like an actual in-world right i
always wondered why it was called halo so well i felt the
same way about metal gear when i when they were talking
about metal gear as like a weapon i was like wait what the
thing actual metal gear is real oh this upcoming chapter is
the longest in the game oh yeah so depending I'm down but I
don't know your schedule if you need to I might call it here
I'm gonna go I could wait I would have been your daddy okay
you gotta go feed your your baby yeah I'm just trying to
keep him company as much as possible so yeah especially
because he's so young people are saying this is a good
mission oh I want to be able to like take our time enjoy it
okay Here.
Yee-bye.
Oh, hammer out.
Yeah, I got a new cat, you guys.
His name is Johnny.
Yeah.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, there you are.
Hello.
Wait, they're still coming out.
Yeah, we can just wrap up here because of the people on
the...
Yeah.
Hey, leave us alone.
Leave us alone.
We got a wrap-up stream.
Yeah, we got a wrap-up stream.
do anything they have no no etiquette no nothing no
etiquette at all yeah none all right do you have it no you
don't have it i don't have it no rockets no no give me
everything you got oh i know what we could do wait hold on
we could jump Let's stop!
Oh, is that the halo?
Wait, no, that can't be...
Nice.
Can't they tell that we're having a girl's night sleepover?
Yeah.
Girl's sleepover.
Oh, well, this is so fun, Barry.
I'm glad.
Yeah, thank you so much for playing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to play more.
Next time we will figure out how to actually legit rocket
jump soon.
It will happen.
I wish there was where I can't not believe they deprived us
of our rocket launcher for this chapter whoa and also I'm on
top oh and also they didn't give us their freaking sniper
rifle either give it to us for like one mission yeah what
was up with that wait did you have to like save the campaign
or is it auto I mean I think it's auto saved yeah because we
are this okay yeah it does look like it yeah
yeah all right all right until next time barrel bug until
next time minto mint mint mint all in how do I leave I don't
know how to leave I can't oh wait no that's how you leave
and you don't come back she kicked me out she kicked me out
Wait, no, I didn't kick you out.
Oh, it kicked you out.
Oh, no, I left.
I left it.
Oh, okay, okay.
Yeah.
Outsu.
Have fun with your new kitty.
Have fun with Johnny.
Thanks.
He's a bit of a menace, but he's so cute.
Oh, no.
Hey, bye-bye.
Bye, booze.
Bye.
Wait, what are your guys just called?
It's complicated.
I still say bug bros, but I think it's...
Yeah, bug bros, or if you want beanie bugs, it's just...
It's just whatever floats your...
People are saying wisps in my chat.
I'm not...
They're not called wisps.
No.
No, no.
Well, whatever, whatever.
I think they're both cute.
Bug bros and beanie bug bros.
Yeah.
I think Ibu is so cute too.
and it reminds me of how how in yugioh protagonist called
their karebo's eyeball eyeball yeah that's what it's kind of
based off of yeah eyeball i just i'm just so yugioh i just
can't stop thinking about yugioh wait why are you yugioh
brain right now i love i i like yugioh yeah yeah i like gx
though i like yugioh do you play or do you just watch well i
play until um But I like playing the main character, Judai's
deck, but he has like a very objectively bad deck.
So I play until somebody stomps, like curb stomps me, and
then I rage quit, and then I don't play again for like two
years until I'm like, wait, I always like Yu-Gi-Oh.
I want to play Yu-Gi-Oh.
That's fair.
Oh, GX, wait, hold on.
I got to look this guy up because I think I know who you're
talking about.
But...
Yeah.
He was on the Nintendo direction.
Why is he, like, why has he overthrown Yu-Gi- Like, no,
don't say that, dude.
Don't say that.
They literally still show so much love.
They show so much love to the OG Yu-Gi-Oh, man.
This is, like, the crown of GX.
Yeah, they do.
Wait, did you ever see?
Did you not see they're making crocs?
No.
Yu-Gi-Oh, Krocs?
Why?
Oh, my God.
Wait, Yu-Gi-Oh, Krocs.
I don't know, though.
I feel like Yu-Gi-G-X was 20 years ago, and they're still
like, yeah, Yu-Gi-X.
because it's so good isn't it?
Is that good?
Um yeah well I have like really really really heavy
nostalgia for it so I don't think I can be an unbiased look
at these crocs wait those are sick oh my god I know right
wait oh my gosh the Kaiba ones are they go hard dude they're
so I love the dark magician girl ones.
And then, you know, the Kaiba ones are...
Like, it's so cool, man.
Whoa.
Wait, I'll show chat.
Look, look, look, you guys.
Look at these.
Yeah.
Oh, they're awesome.
Is Jaden's last name Yuki because of Yugi?
Um, actually, they have a...
So for every Yugi protagonist, they have a theme where their
first name always starts with you.
Uh, Judai is the only one whose first name doesn't start
with you.
but instead his last name starts with you.
But that's why you have Yugi and you have Yusei and you have
the other guys.
Whoa.
I only watched the first season, like Yugi of original.
And then I did play.
And I was like in tournaments as a kid.
Oh, wait, really?
What was your archetype?
I don't remember, but I got my ass beat by some adult at the
bookstore, so I just go in.
I quit.
That's fair.
To be honest, I feel like Yugio is one of the more
excruciating card games to play nowadays.
You think so?
I think so.
I don't know.
Every time...
I'm sure it's like a part of it is like me just not
understanding all of the nuances.
But...
Oh my gosh.
My brain is not brained enough for card games, I think.
So...
It's fun.
I don't know.
Maybe I'll check out GX.
How long is it?
Okay, so basically, four kids dubbed it, but they never
dubbed the last season.
No!
Yeah!
So if you watch the English dub of it, the English dub is
very funny, but you'll be left on a cliffhanger that implies
that the main character is dead because they didn't stop and
they didn't translate the last season where he comes back.
Oh my god!
Did they just think that, like...
I don't know.
Dude, I legit thought he was just straight up dead.
Wait, that's crazy.
Also, I guess that's a spoiler too, no?
Oh.
Well, you don't know.
You don't know how it happens.
What?
They just show his grave and they're like, there he is.
No, it's like he's just missing, I guess.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
You get killed people in the original Yu-Gi-Oh!
I don't want to hear it.
He killed people?
Wait, I don't remember that.
How did he kill people?
Maybe that was in the prototype, Yu-Gi-Oh.
He stabbed them.
They took their cards.
Dude, card games are serious, man.
I know.
Yeah.
In season zero.
Oh, in the manga, he did?
Oh, yeah.
Oh.
Well, they made a brief OVA, I want to say, for the season
zero.
And Yugi, like, is straight up a psychopath.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, my God.
Grandpa, what did you teach him?
Nothing.
Dang.
Well, I mean, yeah, the Shadow Realm, you get sent there,
and it's, like, actual.
Dang.
You're gone.
Well, I guess, uh, see you again.
guys next time whenever we play halo again i hope you guys
have a lot of fun what are you gonna what are you gonna do
oh yeah wait wait we should plug your charity stream oh you
have a charity stream i have a charity stream tomorrow on
the dance center channel raising up money for mental health
so yay yeah yeah yeah we'll we'll she loves mentally ill
people takes one no one baby
No, this is so fun.
Let's do it soon.
Next week?
Yes.
Yeah, yeah.
Akidoki.
Bye-bye.
Have fun with your kitty.
Wait, can you send...
Oh, Tomoe!
Thank you for the raid.
Oh, my goodness.
Welcome in, raiders.
Welcome.
But are you gonna...
Can you send me a...
Wait, no.
Have you sent...
Have you showed a photo of your cat on Twitter?
No.
Okay.
like a weirdo close-up of him, but you're also... Oh, okay.
I think that's what I remember.
Yeah, I'll send you.
I'll send you him right now.
He's so cute.
I want to see.
He's just a little baby.
All my pictures are of him in my lap or, like, looking like
a doofus.
Oh, yeah, you did.
I forgot to respond, but you were like, here are some
screenshots.
I can't send more of my model because there's a cat on my
lap.
I know.
He, like, will sit in my lap on the worst ways and like he's
very persistent because if like my arm if i'm like trying to
move away he's like no no i have to lay here like i have to
ah he's really dumb he's cute yeah he's cute still a kitty
right he's a couple years old but he acts like a kitty yeah
oh eternally a kitten i know i think so he's got no brain
cells he's really stupid like i know some people say that i
about their cats but this guy is like always bumping his
head into stuff like oh wait really yeah like I'll just be
kind of like sitting around and I'll hear like a donk and he
bumps his head like on the on the oven or something no I
guess he's just a clumsy little guy way so cute yeah he's a
baby he has your eyes oh my god like legit my son my son my
son your son your son yeah anyways uh i don't want to yeah i
don't want to keep you up too much but uh bye-bye bye-bye
talk to you later yeah talk to you later bye-bye bye-bye
bye-bye bye-bye bye-bye yeah yeah yeah yeah that was so fun
oh my gosh wait halo was so fun i hope you guys had fine.
I'm gonna chat for it.
I'm gonna take her and I'm gonna make her small.
And I'm gonna go here and I'm gonna do this and I'm gonna do
this.
And I- oh wait there's no chat.
One second.
I'm gonna do...
Oh, sorry.
And this.
I'm going to exit out of the game.
And put on some music.
And then I'm going to put Berry in my coffee.
In my big cup.
dunk her i'm gonna waterboard her
today is ruby's straw ruby berry birthday can you wish your
happy birthday ruby happy birthday let's see um bgm i want
to talk just a little bit before i leave just a few minutes
Um...
Where's my music?
Oh, there we go.
Yeah.
Wayfarer, thank you!
Happy birthday!
I hope you had a great time.
It's funny to see you play it now.
My brother basically forced our sister to play the series
for the first time this past month.
She's not a gamer.
Only plays one game.
It was funny to watch.
I had so much fun.
Oh, that's me.
No, no, stop it.
So my first time joining in, it was a very grand time.
Thanks for joining.
Thanks for hanging out.
Seeking around.
Donk, donk, donk, donk, donk, donk, donk, donk, donk.
Wait.
I'm stirring my coffee with her.
Even though she's behind.
Just pretend.
little bug on me.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, my God.
Yeah.
Halo is so fun.
I didn't know what to expect.
I didn't know how, like, how, like, cinematic and story like
how much lore there would be or anything but
in a roundabout way halo is the reason i watch you wait i
went how so sorry i did miss your super chat i i honestly
need to start remembering to turn off super chats for like
collabs and stuff because i just can't my attention is
divided even more so so it's hard for me to read them but i
do really appreciate everybody that sends them thank you so
so much Halo.
How much, how long is this game?
I don't even know.
OG Halo has a secret sauce that gaming seems to have lost.
Halo 2 is very lore heavy.
I see, I see.
10 levels.
And we're at... You're a little less than halfway.
Oh, I was about to say, like, we're at level 3?
Okay.
Oh, about 8-ish hours.
That's not so bad at all.
Back in the day, games used to be...
Kind of simple, but also we just, we just, we're silly
around.
We're sillying.
We're sillying around about a third of the way.
Yeah, that sounds right.
So fun.
I just completed Halo 2 on Legendary the other day.
Oh, yeah.
I feel, I'm really glad that Barry invited me to play it
because like, you know me, I'd like to, I've been trying to
get through these kinds of series that are influential in
the gaming world and everything.
so the game had a manual that explained the backstory of the
game
the checkpoint respawn system lets you be very silly when
playing right I feel like these kinds of games are so much
more fun and co-op I'm so happy I get to play with Barry
again get to play with Barry again oh my gosh wait I have to
send her something I forgot I forgot
Uh...
Uh, once again?
I wanted to send her a picture I took.
Sorry, I can't tell you guys, though.
Reach is a good stopping point.
Good, good, good.
Any reason you played this and not the new remake?
Mmm.
Honestly, Barry was the one that invited me and she was the
one that, like, picked the games and everything out.
was like okay I'll do whatever you want to do remember to
tea bag the enemy or but that isn't that a huge in this game
you're so right I need to learn how to tea bag wait wait
wait wait she's
on my face
do you think she knows does she know Does she know?
Whoa.
Can
she 360?
Can she do it?
Stompin' on, bugs.
Oh, God, I'm dizzy.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Wow.
This is abused.
Right in the bowl.
She would win every county fair.
Shaken Bayery Syndrome Wait, hold on I can be like an angler
fish Whoa, whoa Never mind, I liked it before
Minky is using the lantern fish Using bug as a lure You
wanna come eat this little bug Oh, this little bug Yeah,
come right over looks so delicious no come right into my
mouth a mint berry shake yeah i don't know how i don't know
how that would be i've got the big mean so pushy yesterday
she's still in the bag though i don't have a spot for it yet
i need to clean you clean no you you welcome a maid into
your home and then what did you expect her to do it for you
phrasing What did I say?
Strawberry book.
I know her new outfit's so cute.
We wanted to be cozy, cozy together.
We wanted to be cozy, cozy together, but she should have
taken off the jacket.
I was searching during stream and came across the classic
Wartog Jump.
There used to be tons of videos like this on YouTube.
Oh, I'll have to check it out later.
Thank you, Deppers.
Thank you, thank you.
Hmm.
talking of the Fumomiki plushie.
I missed out and I'm sad because of it.
No!
Maybe.
Maybe eventually, but...
Maybe instead of turning off Super Chats for a collab, you
could pin a message letting people know you're not reading
live.
Maybe, but sometimes people don't read the...
pin messages.
I can...
It's okay.
I feel more comfortable because if people are donating,
it's, you know...
They want their message to be read, right?
And I would feel more comfortable if I...
Just, uh...
If I...
You know, I don't need to... I don't need to get them.
It's okay.
It bugs me more that the pin message is at the bottom
instead of the top down.
Right!
I don't... I guess they were thinking that because, like,
the...
The... What's it called?
Is at... Like, the... The... Where you...
Input the text is at the bottom!
Then maybe they're like, oh, you'll see it down there
instead of the top.
But it just, because it's a pinned message, it feels like it
should be at the top.
No, right.
It's so strange.
I hate it.
That's my theory, my game theory of why they put it at the
bottom.
Yeah, it needs to be a different color, right?
Something like yellow, something that really stands out.
Oh, but as for the Fumo, I'm not quite sure, but there
might, you know, never knock the chance of there being a
plushie again in the future.
Yes, yes, yes.
But buddy, welcome back, thank
you.
or white anymore, so I'm so...
Oh my gosh.
Wink, wink, wink, wink.
Wink, wink.
Why can't I wink?
.
Will there be a part two to finish the game?
There will be!
Of course, of course!
We must finish.
NTNT.
Guys, what should I have for dinner?
What should I have?
It's okay if you don't want to talk about the Kojima thing.
I was cracking up.
Salmon, that sounds good.
Oh, salmon sounds good.
What did he do now?
It's not that what he did.
Basically,
Kojima has been in working on a game that appears to be the
spiritual successor to Metal Gear called Fizint.
And it was being, you know, helped produced by Sony.
And then yesterday, Sony was just like, they put out a tweet
and they were like, We regret to inform you that we are no
longer working with Hideo Kojima on Fusint.
And two, one, two, two minutes later, Xbox tweeted.
And they said, hey, everybody, hey, everybody, hi, guys, we
are working with Hideo Kojima for Fusint.
Oh,
you knew, you know, the social media person was like, their
fingers were tingling after that.
You, you know, oh man.
It's, um, uh,
my take on it is, you know, I guess complicated, not
complicated, but it's like, I don't, you know, it's really
sad.
to see like a company that you did like, you know, something
that was so influential kind of it's because they're taking
away AstroBot from us.
I'll say it!
They deserve it!
They don't want AstroBot to be the mascot!
They don't deserve it!
But honestly but honestly speaking, it really you know, it
doesn't help anybody to see to see this happen.
You know what I mean?
Like...
It just sucks for all people that enjoy playing video games.
And...
So, you know...
I know the guy probably isn't the easiest to work with.
I mean, a lot of like, very, you know...
Creative minds like him.
Speak your truth, Mikisaba.
Um...
But, you know, I'm sure he's not the easiest to work with.
But at the same time, like, I'm glad that he was able to...
I just want him to be able to make his game, you know?
So, mm-hmm.
It's an Ace Combat 8 live-action prequel trailer this
morning.
I did it!
Oh, my gosh.
I wasn't...
I was too busy working this morning, so...
I doubt he's eccentric to work with at all.
Of course not.
I've never heard anything like that.
But, you know, like console war stuff, it's fun to be like,
Hey, hey, you lose, yeah, Sony snooze, blah, blah.
But, like, in the end, it just doesn't help anybody.
It only hurts everybody.
So it's just kind of, you know, I just wish that, I just
wish that that they were more willing to listen to fans and
care for fans because in the end, the people that buy your
products are the gamers and they're you know, you should
want to keep them around.
That's all.
Hideo Kojima is such a talented young man three weeks
younger than me.
Oh, wait, wait, really?
My favorite part of this stream was you making fun of old
Halo 2001 game.
I'd even join my favorite game even if I felt my age.
it was fun no i had so much fun i play all what are you
talking about i play old games all the time
thank you
yeah um but yeah so uh no you play new games like toho so
true you tried max pain not yet but i feel like probably
after alan wake I might go into Max Payne.
Like, uh...
I was talking to my friend about it, um, recently.
Oh, that's Raspberry.
Maddie.
And she was saying, like...
She was like...
I think she said that Max Payne is her favorite.
Max Payne, I don't know, but she really likes all of them.
But...
Berg.
Oh, she's gone.
My head...
...got lighter.
My head got bigger.
Yeah.
I'll stay on my Xbox and PC and play my PS2.
No, I don't want to watch the industry crash.
I love video games.
I don't want it to crash.
I want us to be able to play video games a long time.
Hey, KSY2, thank you.
Lance, thank you for the time.
Thank you, thank you.
Bug raid.
Hello.
But you need bugs.
whichever way you swang.
Norgo, thank you!
Buggies.
Quit bugging me.
Kapo, thank you.
Something new will come out.
I'm sure, I'm sure.
Hmm.
No.
But, you know.
I don't know.
had fun today.
Otomito.
Otu berry!
Otu bug.
Otu, Otu, Otu.
Thank you for the gifting.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
I will head out to, though.
I probably shouldn't.
Last I saw Johnny, he was very sleepy.
He hasn't been bugging me, but I should go feed him, so.
He was He was, like, napping.
So I was like, okay, he had just fallen asleep.
I was like, this is my chance.
Because usually in the middle of the day, when I'm working,
he will, like, nap for a long time, like a couple hours.
But this time, he napped when I started.
And instead, he bothered me first.
He bothered me while I was trying to get work done.
But yeah, thank you guys so much.
Thank you, thank you.
Johnny Silver.
There I go.
Thank you so much for the pink.
I haven't played much of it myself, but now I know that
putting a plasma grenade on the bottom of the warthog and
then hopping in also does not allow you to grenade jump.
All the grenade jumping was so awesome.
It was great.
But yeah, I'm going to go spend time with my little guy.
And I hope you guys have a great day.
Have a great night.
is killing me.
Oh, ha minto!
Oh, ha minto.
Bye-bye.
Bye-bye to you.
Have a good day.
Have a good time, Joe, and I will see you when I see you
next, and I will haunt you later.
So if you are having anything delicious today, make sure you
leave a little offering for a minto phantom haunting you at
this very moment.
And forever.
Minto, minto, minto, minto!
Bye-bye!
Bye-bye.